monsieur le président
la séance est reprise l'ordre du jour
appelle une déclaration du gouvernement
suivie d'un débat et d'un vote sur cette
déclaration en application de l'article
51 de la constitution relatives à
l'évolution de la situation sanitaire et
aux mesures nécessaires pour y répondre
mes chers collègues cette séance
organisera en deux temps après la
déclaration du gouvernement
la parole sera donnée à un orateur de
chaque groupe en fonction des temps que
nous avons arrêté hier à l'issue de
notre séance de questions au
gouvernement
enfin nous procéderons au vote par
scrutin public en application de
l'article 39 de notre règlement sur
cette déclaration
je vais maintenant donner la parole à
monsieur le premier ministre jean castex
monsieur le premier ministre veut
bienvenue à la tribune le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs le
présent la république s'est exprimé hier
pour présenter à la nation les nouvelles
mesures de lutte contre l'épidémie
kovy qu'il convient désormais de mettre
en place une fois encore vous le savez
la france doit affronter les assauts de
cette crise sanitaire
une crise sanitaire qui dure depuis très
longtemps une crise sanitaire qui mute
et qui évoluent dans des conditions
inquiétante alors une fois encore nous
devons faire face nous devons prendre en
toute connaissance de cause les
décisions que cette situation impose la
gravité de cette troisième vague d'une
certaine façon de cette nouvelle
épidémie
l'impact de ces décisions sur nos
concitoyens qui font face courageusement
et depuis des mois cette pandémie
mondiale
tout cela exigeait que les repentants de
la nation puisse en débattre et
s'exprimer par un vote solennel
dans le cadre fixé par l'article 51 de
la constitution je suis venu vous dire
cet après midi que ces mesures nouvelles
nous apparaissent maintenant
indispensable pour protéger la vie et la
santé de beaucoup de nos concitoyens
particulièrement les plus fragiles elles
sont indispensables pour permettre à
notre pays de franchir ce que nous
espérons toutes et tous être une
dernière étape dans la perspective du
déploiement massif de la vaccination est
donc d'un retour à une vie normale
la troisième vague déferle et frappe un
effet durement l'épidémie s'emballe
depuis la mi mars
en deux semaines le nombre de cas a
augmenté de 55 % pour s'élever
aujourd'hui à environ 38 mille cas par
jour
l'épidémie progresse vite et elle
progresse partout cette forte
accélération et chacun le sait le
résultat de la progression du variant
apparu en fin d'année dernière en
grande-bretagne
nous savons qu'il n'était plus
contagieux
de récents travaux scientifiques
prouvent qu'il est aussi plus dangereux
comme je le constate à chacune de mes
visites dans les établissements de santé
le virus frappe des patients plus jeunes
et des patients en plus grande
proportion sans facteurs de risque liés
à des comorbidités bien évidemment ce
phénomène n'est pas propre à la france
en effet depuis une quinzaine de jours
le nombre de cas quotidiens a triplé en
allemagne il a augmenté de 70% en
belgique et de 40 % aux pays-bas cette
virulence accrue de l'épidémie être
particulièrement préoccupante car elle
survient à un moment où notre système de
santé est déjà mis à lure de
contribution et ce depuis longtemps avec
plus de cinq mille malades de la cofidis
tu es hospitalisés en réanimation c'est
certes moins que le pic de la première
vague mais celui de la deuxième vague
est désormais dépassée face à ce nouveau
virus
nous avons rapidement réagi en prenant
ces derniers mois et ces dernières
semaines plusieurs mesures fortes
maintient depuis fin octobre de la
fermeture de nombreuses activités
établissements recevant du public couvre
feu national depuis la mi-décembre
mesures renforcées dans près de 20
départements couvrant près d'un tiers de
la population et ce depuis le 20 mars
dernier
nous l'avons fait en tenant le plus
grand compte des différences de
situations territoriale différence
particulièrement perceptible en début de
vagues épidémiques
si j'insiste ici devant la haute
assemblée sur la territorialisation des
mesures que nous avons prises
c'est parce que je sais à quel point les
membres du sénat était tout comme moi
très attaché à une adaptation de notre
politique sanitaire aux réalités du
terrain et la stratégie de réponse
territorialisée que nous avons utilisée
depuis le mois de janvier jusqu'à
aujourd'hui était la bonne car
l'épidémie frappe est alors nos
territoires de manière très hétérogène
il n'y avait pas de raison d'appliquer
un durcissement des mesures dans les
territoires où le virus circule est très
peu mais aujourd'hui le variant
britannique poursuit son accélération
dans de telles conditions
que devons nous aussi accélérée c'est à
dire prendre des mesures renforcées de
façon à briser la spirale épidémique
enclenchée depuis quelques semaines et
il accélère malheureusement sur
l'ensemble dû territoire métropolitain
depuis une dizaine de jours sur les 96
départements 92
connaissent une accélération de la
circulation virale avec des rythmes
parfois spectaculaires supérieure à 20%
sur une semaine dans la moitié des
départements et de plus de 40 %
d'augmentation dans une vingtaine
d'entre eux c'est par exemple le cas du
département des pyrénées-orientales où
le taux d'incidence a progressé de 73%
en sept jours c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons décidé sous
l'autorité du président de la république
d'étendre à l'ensemble dû territoire
métropolitain les mesures qui
s'appliquait déjà dans les dix-neuf
départements les plus touchés par
l'épidémie
ces nouvelles mesures entreront en
vigueur samedi soir à 19 heures pour
être pleinement applicable le dimanche 4
avril et ce jusqu'au 3 mai soit pour une
durée de quatre semaines
face à la situation actuelle en effet il
nous faut agir fortement à l'échelle
nationale selon les mêmes règles et les
mêmes calendrier pour tous
en prenant une mesure nationale nous
souhaitons aussi préserver l'offre
hospitalière des régions moins durement
touchés qui pourrait fournir des
capacités de repli pour les régions
davantage en tension il nous faut
cependant faire une exception pour les
territoires et départements d'outre-mer
dans la situation sanitaire n'est
évidemment pas comparable à celle de la
métropole ni même du reste d'un
territoire à l'autre compte tenu de leur
éloignement géographique ils
continueront donc à observer des règles
spécifiques et adaptées aux évolutions
épidémique propres à chacun d'entre eux
comme l'indiqué hier le présent de la
république les règles qui s'appliqueront
à compter de samedi soir au territoire
national seront identiques à celles qui
ont été mis en place mise en place
depuis le 20 mars dernier dans les
dix-neuf départements soumis à des
mesures renforcées le couvre-feu sera
maintenu à 19h les conditions
d'ouverture ou de fermeture de commerces
au vairon mêmes critères et conditions
le télétravail sera systématisé quatre
jours par semaine minimum pour tous les
emplois publics
privé où cela est possible les motifs de
sorties et de déplacement seront
encadrés selon les mêmes termes
il restera possible de se déplacer de se
promener de faire du sport sans
limitation de durée dans un rayon de 10
km autour de chez soi en revanche les
rassemblements au regroupement de plus
de 6 personnes resteront interdits enfin
une attestation précisant le motif du
déplacement sera exigée au delà des 10
km et après la fin du prochain week-end
prolongé de pâques les déplacements
inter régionaux seront restreints à
quelques motifs impérieux ces motifs
incluront évidemment les déplacements
professionnels mais aussi se lier un
motif familial comme par exemple
accompagné ou aller chercher un enfant
chez un parent un grand parent ou un
proche
nous sommes en effet un gouvernement
pragmatique et une certaine souplesse
est toujours nécessaire pour permettre
aux règles d'être mieux appropriée
j'observe du reste que l'immense
majorité de nos concitoyens respectent
spontanément les règles en vigueur
faisant preuve en cela d'un sens des
responsabilités et d'incivisme qui
déshonore mais je constate aussi avec
vous qu'une minorité d'entre eux s'y
refuse et je veux condamner devant vous
sans réserve
l'inconscience et l'irresponsabilité de
certains qui se croit sans doute
invincible ou peut-être même immortel
alors même que les ravages de la maladie
nous démontre chaque jour que personne
n'est à l'abri du virus
ces gestes inconséquent qu'il s'agissait
rassemblement festif du non respect du
couvre-feu ou du refus du port du masque
doit être prévenue est sanctionné c'est
la raison pour laquelle j'ai demandé au
ministre de l'intérieur d' accroître le
nombre de policiers de gendarmes
affectés à cette tâche
nous veillerons notamment à ce que
l'interdiction des rassemblements de
plus de six personnes sur la voie
publique soit strictement respectée la
consommation d'alcool dans l'espace
public sera interdite
sur arrêté préfectoral est en lien
étroit avec les maires l'accès à
certains sites propices à des
rassemblements un extérieur comme les
quais berges place pourraient être
interdits en fonction des circonstances
locales
il sera enfin demandé un nouveau parquet
de poursuivre systématiquement les
hauteurs de récidive portant sur
l'organisation d'évènements clandestins
susceptibles de mettre en danger la vie
d'autrui
pour autant ces comportements ne doivent
pas masquer je les dis et je le répète
la résilience et la haute conscience
citoyenne de l'immense majorité des
français partout sur le territoire qui
sans doute proteste s'agace des mesures
et des freins mis à leur quotidien et
s'interrogent parfois à raison mais qui
se montre respectueux des règles c'est à
dire finalement respectueux des autres
autres décisions fortes que la situation
nous contraint de prendre fermer les
établissements scolaires les crèches
ainsi que les activités périscolaires et
extrascolaires
tout a été fait mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs pour repousser au maximum
cette décision et je sais qu'il existait
dans notre pays comme dans cette
assemblée un très large consensus en
faveur du maintien de l'accueil de tous
les enfants dans les établissements
scolaires la france et du reste et vous
le savez le pays d'europe qui a le moins
fermer ses écoles
rappelons en effet que des écoles sont
restées fermées moins de dix semaines en
france depuis le début de la pandémie
contre 24 en allemagne 26 au royaume uni
et 30,2 en italie je crois que nous
pouvons en être fiers fiers d'avoir
maintenu cette exigence républicaine
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
toujours considéré que si nous devions
et je ne m'en suis jamais caché devant
vous utilisez
ce levier alors il nous faudrait le
faire un ultime recours et dans des
conditions qui en réduisent au maximum
l'impact
nous y sommes les écoles les collèges et
les lycées ne sont pas épargnée par
l'épidémie et notamment parce varié en
anglais depuis deux semaines le taux
d'incidence augmente plus vite chez les
enfants et les adolescents que dans la
population générale
ce qui a pour conséquence dans le strict
respect de nos propres normes sanitaires
de provoquer des fermetures de classes
et d'écoles de plus en plus nombreuses
nous devions donc reprendre l'initiative
en décidant que les établissements
scolaires seront fermés pendant trois
semaines en optimisant comme cela avait
été suggéré par beaucoup la période des
vacances printemps deux façon à ce que
les conséquences sur les enfants soient
les moins pénalisante possible
concrètement vous l'avez entendu la
semaine prochaine où il n'y aura que
quatre jours d'école raison du lundi de
pâques tous les établissements scolaires
assureront leur enseignement à distance
au cours des deux semaines suivantes du
12 au 25 avril tous les élèves de toutes
les zones académiques seront en vacances
de printemps ce qui implique une
modification du calendrier des vacances
de pâques
je mesure tout à fait l'impact de ces
décisions sur la vie de nombreuses
familles mais aussi dans l'organisation
des entreprises
mais c'est le moyen d'atteindre notre
objectif de pouvoir à la fois agir sur
la contamination en milieu scolaire avec
en même temps l'impact le plus limité
possible sur l'année scolaire de nos
enfants
comme lors du premier confinement un
dispositif d'accueil des enfants des
personnels prioritaires sera organisée
dès la semaine prochaine en lien avec
l'éducation nationale et les
collectivités locales
les salariés qui seront conduits à
garder leurs enfants à domicile faute
d'autres solutions bénéficieront du
dispositif d'activité partielle qui
s'appliquait déjà lors du premier
confinement il leur suffira de se
signaler auprès de leur employeur
qui mettra en oeuvre la procédure de
déclaration auprès des services
compétents de l'état pour les élèves de
l'enseignement supérieur les étudiants
les règles en vigueur qui prévoient un
enseignement essentiellement en distanti
elles seront maintenues sans remettre en
cause la possibilité donnée récemment
aux étudiants de pouvoir revenir
une journée par semaine en présentiel
dans des conditions strictes
je consulterai demain l'ensemble des
associations d'élus locaux afin
d'évoquer avec elle les modalités
concrètes de mise en oeuvre de
l'ensemble de ces mesures s'agissant
notamment de la continuité des services
publics et en particulier de l'accueil
des enfants des personnels prioritaires
bien évidemment les dispositifs de
soutien et d'accompagnement économique
et sociale dans le sénat a bien voulu
souvent reconnaître l'intensité tout en
préconisant des améliorations seront
prolongées autant de temps que
nécessaire
d'ores et déjà certaines mesures ont été
complétés notamment en faveur des
commerces fermés depuis février dans les
grands centres commerciaux ou de ceux
qui ont accumulé des stocks importants
du fait des périodes de fermeture
je pense également aux entreprises de
plus grande taille
affecté par de longs mois de crise c'est
le sens de l'aide exceptionnelle pour la
prise en charge des coûts fixes qui
étaient mis en place depuis hier 31 mars
ces mesures que je vous présente cet
après midi sont difficiles mais elles
sont indispensables
surtout elles sont éclairées par la
perspective de la campagne de
vaccination qui progresse et s'amplifie
tous les jours et qui nous donne une
vraie raison de penser que nous avançons
vers la sortie vers la voie d'une sortie
de crise
plus de huit millions de nos concitoyens
sont désormais vaccinés dont près de 2,8
millions avec deux doses l'objectif de
mon gouvernement reste le même
10 millions de vaccinés mi-avril 20
millions à la mi mai et 30 millions mi
juin en veillant bien sûr à ce que la
commission européenne fasse respecter
les obligations des industriels quant au
calendrier de livraison des doses
nous saurons donc au rendez vous des
objectifs que j'avais et danser devant
vous mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
le 17 décembre dernier lors du débat
organisé dans ce même hémicycle sur la
stratégie vaccinale
j'avais alors à danser la vaccination de
15 millions de personnes d'ici la fin du
premier semestre
nous y serons très largement la
mobilisation est totale pour que nous
puissions vacciner sans relâche et le
rythme
vous le voyez aux chiffres quotidiens ne
cesse de s'accélérer depuis déjà trois
semaines ce rythme quotidien est plus
élevé que celui de nos voisins allemands
italiens ou espagnols
surtout nous sommes clairement les mieux
positionnés pour la vaccination des
personnes pour la vaccination des
personnes les plus vulnérables à la
maladie
et oui je veux saluer toutes les
personnes impliquées dans les centres de
vaccination mis en place dans les
mairies les établissements hospitaliers
ou encore les professionnels de ville
nous en comptons plus de 1500 à 1700
pardon aujourd'hui et d'autres encore
doivent s'ouvrir dans les prochaines
semaines je salue également la
mobilisation des professionnels de ville
plus de cinquante mille médecins et
20000 officines de pharmacie se sont
engagés dans la vaccination en un mois
ils ont administré près de 1 million 700
mille doses aux patients éligibles à
compter de la semaine prochaine
vingt-cinq premiers infirmiers vont se
lancer à leur tour dans la vaccination
toujours la semaine prochaine près de 1
million 400 mille doses supplémentaires
seront utilisables sur le terrain suivi
de trois millions de doses
supplémentaires en avril et 3,6 millions
en mai ce mois d'avril vous le savez qui
verra l'arrivée d'un nouveau vaccin
celui de johnson & johnson qui a la
particularité de ne nécessiter qu'une
seule dose
il sera alors possible dans les
prochaines semaines comme le chef de
l'état l'a annoncé hier d'ouvrir la
vaccination un de nouvelles tranches
d'âge le 15 avril pour les personnes
âgées de 60 à 69 ans le 15 mai pour les
personnes âgées de 50 à 59 ans le 15
juin pour tous les autres nous
travaillons également en lien avec tous
les secteurs professionnels concernés à
la réouverture des lieux et activités
aujourd'hui fermé cette réouverture
interviendra lorsque les conditions
sanitaires seront réunies et le moment
venu le gouvernement présentera cette
stratégie de réouverture devant le
parlement
il nous faut aussi nous prononcer il
nous faut aussi nous prononcer mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs sur les
conditions d'organisation des élections
régionales et départementales prévues
les 13 et 20 juin prochains
ces élections ont déjà été reporté une
première fois raison du coc vie comme je
lai déjà indiqué et comme je le redis
cet après midi devant la haute assemblée
seules des raisons sanitaires impérieuse
de nature à compromettre l'organisation
de la campagne du scrutin pourrait
justifier un nouveau report en
application de la loi du 22 février
dernier le conseil scientifique a rendu
sur ce sujet
un avis lundi j'observe avec vous que
cet avis particulièrement balancer
ne que cet avis ne préconise pas
explicitement un report des élections
c'est donc clairement le scénario de
leur maintien que nous privilégions à ce
stade
j'ajoute j'ajoute que les décisions que
nous débattons cet après midi y compris
celles relatives à l'accélération de la
vaccination devrait avoir pour effet
d'améliorer la situation sanitaire à
l'échéance du mois de juin
cependant le conseil scientifique
le conseil scientifique formule des
recommandations précises quant aux
conditions de l'organisation et de la
tenue de ces élections tandis que les
mesures nouvelles qui entreront en
vigueur ce week-end et pour quatre
semaines pourrait avoir un effet sur le
déroulement de la campagne
nous avons donc le devoir collectif de
nous assurer que l'ensemble de ces
conditions édictées par le conseil
scientifique pourront être effectivement
satisfaites et que leur mise en oeuvre
très concrète ne viendra pas altéré
l'expression libre et sécurisée du vote
de nos concitoyens à cet effet je vais
engager sans délai une consultation des
partis politiques représentés au
parlement parce qu'ils concourent à
l'expression du suffrage et des
associations d'élus locaux notamment les
maires chargé de l'organisation
matérielle des opérations de vote
un débat fondé sur l'article 51 de la
constitution sera ensuite organisée au
parlement
sur l'ensemble de ces éléments tel est
le sens monsieur le président du rapport
que je vous remets très tout à l'heure
et dont nous nous sommes entretenu
conformément à la loi du 22 février
dernier
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs des
semaines particulièrement difficiles
sont encore devant nous plus que jamais
les personnels soignants dans le
dévouement et la bravoure sont
admirables depuis 14 mois
mérite
notre soutien et la reconnaissance de la
nation toute entière
je me rentre régulièrement dans les
établissements de santé pour leur
manifester ce soutien je sais car ils me
le disent ce qu'ils endurent
je sais combien ils se battent malgré la
fatigue malgré la lassitude pour sauver
des vies notre système hospitalier va
tenir le choc et il va le tenir grâce à
eux nous les y aiderons en continuant de
mobiliser tous les leviers possibles en
déplafonnant les heures supplémentaires
dans les établissements de santé en
mobilisant tous les renforts possibles
en particulier les professionnels de
ville les retraités les étudiants santé
les 26000 professionnels inscrits à la
réserve sanitaire civile mais également
la réserve militaire en organisant la
collaboration entre le public et les
privés et le privé qui n'a jamais été
aussi fluide je le dis devant vous un
organisant des évacuations sanitaires
depuis les régions les plus touchées
l'activation de l'ensemble de ces
leviers dont nous permettre d' armée
jusqu'à dix mille deux cents lits de
réanimation et d'accueillir tous les
malades qui en auront besoin
face à cette crise sans précédent et à
la part d'incertitude que comporte cette
épidémie mon gouvernement a agi avec
cohérence et pragmatisme gérer une crise
sanitaire s'est conjugué mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
plusieurs critères dans le seul intérêt
du bien commun il y a évidemment d'abord
et en premier lieu les critères
épidémiologique et sanitaire et donc les
avis des scientifiques et des médecins
il me faut le dire et le répéter ici
devant le sénat et la nation toute
entière il n'y a pas d'opposition entre
le pouvoir politique et le pouvoir
médical
nous tenons le plus grand compte des
avis des analyses des modèles et des
prévisions des experts
conseils scientifiques et médicaux mais
et c'est bien là le rôle du gouvernement
nous avons également le devoir jeudi
bien le devoir d' intégrer dans nos
prises de décisions d'autres
considérations qui relève de la
dimension sociale scolaire psychologique
économique de notre pays et de notre
société ces critères se modélise
sûrement moins bien et leur impact est
sûrement moins immédiat mais leurs
effets sont un an après le début de la
pandémie
beaucoup mieux connu c'est dans la
combinaison difficile très difficile de
l'ensemble de ces critères que doit être
recherchée l' équilibre des décisions
qui nous appartient de prendre et c'est
aussi cet équilibre qui conditionne la
temporalité de ces décisions mais en fin
de compte et le moment dans lequel nous
nous trouvons l'illustrent parfaitement
la mer des priorités le premier des
critères qui finira toujours par
s'imposer
c'est la protection sanitaire de nos
concitoyens comme toujours c'est dans
l'unité et dans le recours aux valeurs
de solidarité et de responsabilité que
nous trouverons les ressources pour
faire face à ce choc grave' inédit et
complexe
c'est la caractéristique profondes de
cette crise elle fait appel au sens des
responsabilités de tous et de chacun
c'est cette responsabilité que je viens
partager avec vous cet après midi je
vous remercie
merci monsieur le premier ministre
merci
nous allons maintenant aborder la suite
de notre débat et je vais donner la
parole aux orateurs des groupes
premier orateur le président hervé
marseille pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
[Applaudissements]
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues le parlement est de
nouveau saisi au titre de l'article 50-1
de la constitution pour débattre des
nouvelles mesures sanitaires annoncé
hier soir par monsieur le président de
la république
ces mesures monsieur le premier ministre
que vous relayer cet après midi pourrait
être très largement commentée
je ne vais pas me lancer dans cet
exercice ces mesures étaient
indispensables en raison de l'évolution
de la pandémie
nous partageons l'idée qu'il ne fallait
pas revenir un confinement dures du type
de celui que nous avons connu en mars
2020 nous paraît évident qu'un tel
confinement ne serait plus accepter de
la même manière par nos concitoyens
la peur et la sidération laissé place à
l'inquiétude
la lassitude et même parfois une
certaine colère mais l'évolution des
indicateurs sanitaires imposer de
nouvelles mesures
je suis persuadé et je veux croire que
celles qui ont été proposées hier on
était pesé réfléchi à l'aune des
indicateurs dont vous disposez vous
venez de le dire à l'instant elles sont
une synthèse de la raison sanitaire mais
aussi de la prise en compte nécessaire
des intérêts économiques sociaux du pays
voire psychologiques
pour autant ces mesures suscitent des
intérêts des interrogations que nous
souhaiterions voir lever d'abord le
passage d'une capacité de 7 mille lits
en réanimation à 10000 a été quelque
chose qui nous a valablement surpris
mais alors que nous en parlons depuis
des mois comment ceci est il devenu
réaliser
on parlait d'argent magique aujourd'hui
nous avons des lits magique d'où sortent
ces lits et pourquoi ne pas est il
possible de les mobiliser auparavant
encore plus problématique qu'est la
question du personnel qui permettra de
les faire fonctionner le président a
bien fait a bien fait état que tout le
potentiel de la réserve sanitaire
seraient mobilisés mais cela
permettra-t-il de rendre effectif
l'utilisation de ces nouveaux lits
s'agissant de la stratégie vaccinale
jusqu'ici outre les seniors seuls les
soignants était prioritaire pour se
faire vacciner et l'ouverture de cette
priorité à de nouvelles catégories les
enseignants les policiers les pompiers
est une bonne chose mais risque de
brouiller la lisibilité de la stratégie
et surtout de donner lieu à des demandes
reconventionnelles par exemple pourquoi
les enseignants et pourquoi pas les
atsem dans les communes qui sont
pourtant eux aussi au contact des
enfants au quotidien
de même pourquoi pas les chauffeurs de
bus ou les caissières de supermarchés
dont on a tant parlé il ya quelques mois
n'y at il pas là un risque de
revendications tout azimut et
d'incompréhension de la part d'un
certain nombre de professions exposées
toujours au sujet des vaccins mais cette
fois en amont au niveau de la production
et la fourniture des doses les annonces
présidentielles sont très volontariste
et optimiste
nous allons accélérer les achats vous
l'avez dit on ne peut qu'être d'accord
mais tout à chacun sait bien que les
doses manque aujourd'hui encore on
constate qu astrazeneca a livré 30
millions au lieu des 120 promise comment
allons-nous accélérer les achats de même
nous allons devenir le premier continent
au monde en termes de production de
vaccins fils président qu'ils
l'affirment
tout le monde s'en réjouir comment cela
va-t-il se passer
où seront les usines de production
comment ceci va être organisé parmi les
annonces d'hier
la fermeture des écoles est sans doute
la plus forte annonce vous avez annoncé
des consultations avec les associations
d'élus
c'est une bonne chose car beaucoup
s'inquiètent sur le domaine périscolaire
en particulier fermer les écoles suppose
que les familles s'organisent mais aussi
les écoles elles-mêmes et les
collectivités
le chef de l'état
pourtant on n'a pas parlé des autotests
alors qu'ils sont très utilisés en
grande bretagne en allemagne
pourquoi faisons-nous l'impasse sur les
autotests en france pourquoi avons-nous
été moins réactif que nos voisins
européens pour nous en équipe et autres
grands absents du débat
le pass sanitaires c'est pourtant un
sujet majeur tant au niveau
communautaire qu'au niveau national
toutes les restrictions sanitaires
seront élevés une fois que les publics à
risque auront été vaccinés
enfin on peut se demander s'il n'aurait
pas été possible de conserver au moins
un peu de différenciation local s'il
n'aurait pas été envisageable de jouer
la carte la déconcentration et de plus
inciter les praticiens hospitaliers à
innover vous l'aurez compris monsieur le
ministre il s'agit là d'interrogation
elles ne remettent pas en cause l'idée
que nous nous faisons de votre action
s'agit pas de défiance il s'agit pas de
mettre en doute la bonne foi du
gouvernement
il s'agit pas de contester l'idée que
vous défendez la protection sanitaire
des français en ménageant autant que
possible les autres intérêts de la
nation
vous avez parlé des aides économiques
chacun ici constate que le gouvernement
l'état a fait beaucoup ces derniers mois
pour aider les entreprises pour aider
les commerçants mais nous ne voterons
pas cet après midi monsieur le premier
ministre
car une fois de plus nous débattons de
mesures qui ont déjà été prises notre
groupe ne prendra pas part un vote qui
semble relever davantage de l'exercice
de style platonique et cosmétiques
nous avons compris que notre principal
outil de travail nous parlementaires
était le poste de télévision
au-delà de cette ironie
nous avons un problème institutionnel
monsieur le premier ministre c'est cela
dont nous voulons vous parler
aujourd'hui les mesures sanitaires vont
dans le bon sens mais on prend des
mesures qui touchent aux libertés
publiques
vous avez dit ce matin l'action que nous
menons se fait naturellement dans un
cadre constitutionnel mais sont surtout
des mesures administratives
réglementaires
c'est vrai mais quand on touche à la
liberté d'aller et venir
quand on touche à la liberté du commerce
quand on empêche les gens d'aller et
venir d'une région à l'autre d'un
département à l'autre
c'est sûrement très nécessaire
d'ailleurs beaucoup de ces mesures nous
les abbruzes jours mais simplement il
s'agit de libertés publiques ça va au
delà du réglementaire ça va au delà de
l'administration et il n'est pas anormal
que le parlement puisse apprécier la
proportionnalité des mesures qui ont été
prises
il n'y a rien d'offensant monsieur le
premier ministre ni pour le président de
la république ni pour votre gouvernement
que les parlementaires puissent émettre
a priori une opinion formuler des
recommandations n'est pas normal à nos
yeux qu'un homme seul
fut-il le président et quelle que soit
sa qualité puisse décider seul en
s'appuyant sur un conseil de défense et
prendre des décisions nous sommes amenés
à constater
semaine après semaine vous avez parlé ce
matin j'ai écouté la réponse que
monsieur le ministre en fait à
l'assemblée nationale est la vôtre
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
dit la démocratie c'est la transparence
est ce que vous croyez franchement que
le conseil de défense est un exemple de
transparence
quelle est la place du conseil de
défense dans nos institutions
aujourd'hui si le conseil de défense est
devenu un corps central indispensable
dans l'action qui est menée aujourd'hui
le parlement lui a disparu de la prise
de décision on va même jusqu'à créer des
machins je pense que le général de
gaulle les eaux rappeler comme ça avec
un certain nombre de sites web de
citoyens tirés au sort pour savoir ce
qu'ils pensent de la difficulté maximale
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs on ne les entend
plus le président a décidé de parler
directement à l'opinion
je pense que c'est un exercice très
dangereux et on en est déjà fait la
terrible épreuve avec l'épisode des
gilet jaune
ça paraît déjà très loin mais c'est
finalement très récente et quand on joue
avec l'opinion faut s'attendre à ce
qu'un jour ça puisse finir par le
capitole ou par chez nous sur les champs
elysées avec des milliers de ses rêves
qui sont obligés de protéger nos
institutions il y a une constitution il
y à des institutions et le sujet dont je
veux essentiellement vous parler
aujourd'hui monsieur le premier ministre
c'est cette alerte
nous ne pouvons pas être reléguée
aujourd'hui attendre des sujets des
directives des annonces qui nous
viennent sur les écrans ceci ne peut
plus durer
si demain d'autres et quand je vois les
sondages on peut s'inquiéter parfois
arriver au plus haut niveau de l'état ou
s'il y avait une compte une cohabitation
comment fonctionnerait notre pays avec
de tels pouvoirs concentrés entre les
mêmes mains
la question est très grave et c'est un
sujet qui nous sommes nous mobiliser
aujourd'hui c'est pas un sujet
inquiétant c'est simplement un sujet qui
nous alertent temps les pouvoirs sont
concentrés
alors monsieur le premier ministre et
parlait à l'instant même aussi des
élections puisque ceux ci doit donner
lieu
je vous en remercie un débat dans les
prochains jours vous aviez précédemment
déclaré que
vous vous appuyez sur les conclusions du
conseil scientifique
je reconnais comme vous que les
conclusions sont balancés conseil
scientifique a fait et taille s'est
appuyé sur un principe de certains
humoristes que j'appuie que
j'appellerais le principe de chevalier
et laspalès c'est vous qui voyez donc
évidemment monsieur le premier ministre
il va falloir trouver d'autres éléments
pour notre part nous considérons qu'il
ya des dates électorale qui a des modes
de scrutin et que sauf événement
extrêmement important il n'y a pas lieu
de modifier tout ça dernier point
monsieur le premier ministre
l'europe beaucoup des sujets dont nous
parlons relève de l'action européenne
on a déjà eu l'occasion ici d'en parler
notamment au moment des questions au
gouvernement le plan de relance nous
inquiète parce qu'il y aura aussi un
après et nous devons préparer les choses
et nous sommes inquiets de ce qui se
passe en allemagne avec la cour
constitutionnelle de karlsruhe
il ya 750 milliards en jeu nous sommes
inquiets du problème des frontières
nous sommes inquiets évidemment des
problèmes des vaccins et c'est en europe
que tout cela se passe alors dans
d'autres pays monsieur le premier
ministre
en italie on a fait un gouvernement
d'union silva de monsieur salvini à la
gauche italienne
on voit les efforts madame merkel avec
les länder
on sait que tout ça est très compliqué
que c'est un énorme travail
alors on vous fait confiance monsieur le
premier ministre mais de grâce qu'il y
ait une autre pratique institutionnelle
je vous remercie
merci monsieur le président
je vais maintenant donner la parole aux
présidents patrick kanner pour le groupe
socialiste écologistes et républicains
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues le 29 octobre dernier
vous veniez devant nous pour nous
annoncer les mesures nécessaires au vu
de l'évolution de la situation sanitaire
j'avais souligné la difficulté de votre
tâche ainsi que la responsabilité qui
était la vôtre devant les français
malgré les errements malgré les fautes
malgré la trop grande verticalité de
votre gestion de crise le groupe
socialiste écologistes et républicains
avaient voté en faveur de votre
déclaration
notre vote ne valait pas soutien à
l'action de votre gouvernement
notre vote ne valait pas quitus pour
votre gestion de la crise nous avons
voté en faveur des français et de leur
santé
cinq mois plus tard la situation a
changé
ou plutôt elle n'a pas changé
vous n'avez pas tiré les enseignements
des précédents de séquences la gestion
de l'épidémie s'est dégradée la
concentration du pouvoir s'est renforcée
cinq mois plus tard vous êtes devant
nous et nous ne savons pas pourquoi
monsieur le premier ministre
en déclinant les propos de l'oracle
présidentielle vous ne nous associer pas
notre vote serait unanimement
défavorable pour l'ensemble du parlement
que cela ne changerait rien cela fait
des mois que nous vous demandons plus de
transparence plus de clarté plus de
démocratie sanitaire cela fait des mois
que vous balayer d'un revers de main aux
nombreuses propositions
cela fait des mois que vous prenez les
chambres parlementaires pour un
paillasson au service de la doxa
élyséenne
le parlement vote oui ils votent
quand il a discuté un texte un texte
qu'il a travaillé un texte qu'il a
amendé
là on ne discute de rien on a man de
rien on acclame on conspue c'est
toujours le même schéma
le bunker du conseil de défense suffit
la parole du président suffit le premier
ministre répète et le parlement
enregistre vous ne pardonnerait donc
monsieur le premier ministre que mon
intervention se base sur l'intervention
du président de la république plutôt que
sur la vôtre le président de la
république hier soir a tenu à justifier
son action pour éviter tout mea culpa si
certaines erreurs ont été confessé du
bout des lèvres
aucun mot n'a été prononcé pour les
morts de la pandémie
ou si peu pour combler ce manque je
tiens à avoir une pensée pour nos
compatriotes qui ont été touchés par ce
virus avec parfois des conséquences sur
le long terme
pour ceux qui ont perdu des proches pour
ceux qui se bat actuellement contre
cette maladie
bientôt plus de 100000 des nôtres ne
seront plus à nos côtés probablement
davantage si l'on compte les effets des
nombreuses déprogrammation dans des
hôpitaux
nous payons aujourd'hui les conséquences
des choix du président de la république
il faut le dire il décide seul
il doit assumer seul il dit avoir gagné
du temps de liberté pour les français
mais de quelle liberté parlons nous
depuis la fin janvier
chaque semaine les français sont en
alerte devant les rumeurs d'une
intervention présidentielle
chaque semaine ou presque de nouveaux
territoires sont touchés par des
restrictions
l'exécutif s'est félicité de longs mois
et déraisonnablement de ne pas avoir
écouté les scientifiques qui préconisait
des mesures de freinage plus forte dès
fin janvier en raison de l'apparition
des variants et pourtant la flambée
annoncée a bien eu lieu
nous sommes en plein dedans ainsi sans
associer le parlement où des français
votre gouvernement applique la décision
du président de la république en
laissant le virus circule et un niveau
élevé depuis deux mois
pourtant le conseil scientifique avait
indiqué fin janvier je cite si nous ne
réussissons pas à endiguer la
progression du virus
ce avec des mesures fortes nous risquons
d'être confrontés à des pics épidémiques
similaires à ceux observés en mars avril
et en novembre 2020 voire plus élevé
vous même monsieur le premier ministre
vous même le 28 janvier lors d'une femme
e comité de liaison parlementaire alors
que le variant anglais ne représentait
que 10 % des infections nous à ficher
des projections qui montrait un
emballement inévitable de l'épidémie
inévitable ces projections plaidé
clairement pour de nouvelles mesures
vous même et aussi votre ministre de la
santé sembliez convaincu de cela j'ai
mes notes
gevo expression et celle de monsieur
vers ans à l'époque nous les soutenions
d'ailleurs car nous le savions
nécessaire les français étaient prêts
pour ces nouveaux sacrifices
mais non mais non l'épidémiologiste en
chef celui pour qui aucun sujet et
inaccessible au but de son intelligence
hors du commun en a décidé autrement
le pari du trou de souris du président
de la république ait perdu qu'il le dise
s'il assume qu'il s'excuse
car cela aurait pu être écartée lui qui
voulait éviter une dictature sanitaire a
provoqué une débâcle
le résultat de cela c'est un nouveau
confinement et le tri des patients voilà
deux termes que l'on n'entend pas dans
la bouche des membres de l'exécutif est
encore aujourd'hui confinement et tri
mais ce n'est pas parce que le mot même
pas des choses qu'elle n'existe pas
quand on restreint la liberté de
circulation quand on ferme les écoles
quand on ferme les commerces aux
consignes canton des programmes
massivement des opérations au tri cette
politique résulte du choix fait par un
homme dans une démarche de concentration
à l'excès de ses prérogatives
constitutionnelles
je le rappelle ici au plateau la
politique de santé ne fait pas partie du
domaine réservé du président de la
république
et si monsieur premier ministre le
gouvernement et vous l'avait dit ce
matin peut restreindre la liberté par
décret c'est parce que le parlement lui
a délégué cette possibilité par
ordonnance nous connaissons la
complexité d'une telle crise nous ne
nions pas les difficultés de gestion
qu'il entraîne et nous sommes toujours
prêts à agir à vos côtés mais il faut
nous en donner la possibilité dès cet
automne nous avons interrogé sur
l'organisation de la stratégie vaccinale
notre seul espoir pour sortir de cette
crise sanitaire nous appelions le
gouvernement à mettre en place
rapidement un plan clair net et précis
de vaccination ce n'est pas de la
polémique mais un rappel de la prise en
compte de l'urgence absolue par
l'exécutif vous étiez rassure en nous
affirmant que vous étiez dans l'action
alors que quelques semaines plus tard
vous n'avez été que dans la réaction
c'est le dos au mur que vous réagissez
comme d'habitude comme aujourd'hui
ce retard a un coût économique social et
humain conséquent ce manque
d'anticipation associée à une stratégie
assumée de la lenteur à laquelle vous
avez heureusement renoncer doit
s'effacer au profit d'une mobilisation
générale que vous annoncez mais qui ne
se traduit pas encore dans les chiffres
résultat en france seuls 13 % de la
population a reçu au moins une dose de
vaccin nous sommes au delà de la 20e
place des pays qui vaccinent le plus je
connais votre argument chez le premier
ministre
notre situation n'est pas pire
qu'ailleurs votre position me fait
penser cet adage québécois bien connu
quand on se regarde on se désole quand
on se compare on se console ce premier
ministre nous ne voulons pas être
consolé nous voulons être les plus
performants et tout faire pour que
l'europe ne soit pas le bouc émissaire
de ses difficultés
le 3 décembre dernier vous nous
annonciez que 15 millions de personnes
seraient vaccinés avant le printemps
soit fin mars
fin mars nous y sommes et 8 millions de
personnes ont reçu une dose soit la
moitié de ce que vous aviez annoncé les
retards de livraison n'explique pas tout
quid de la désorganisation
quid des volte face par exemple sur les
vaccinodromes hier soir le président de
la république a annoncé deux nouvelles
arrivées dax 1 de la production aussi de
vaccins en france tant mieux mais de
nous les chiffres montrent les nous
expliquez nous comment vous allez
réaliser cela c'est comme cela qu'on
associe le parlement a les français
hier soir le président de la république
a annoncé un plan de sortie de crise il
aurait pu parler de déconfinement comme
au printemps dernier sur ce sujet je
ferai les mêmes requêtes
donnez-nous les chiffres montraient les
nous expliquez nous comment vous croire
qu'on le président de la république ou
le porte parole du gouvernement
dans un savant mélange de madame irma de
pinocchio annoncé un retour à la vie
normale
mi avril et que nous discutons
aujourd'hui d'un confinement auquel vous
êtes maintenant acculé pour ne pas avoir
su l'anticiper hier soir le président de
la république a annoncé de nouveaux lits
de réanimation
mes chers collègues comment monter à 10
milles alors qu'il ya moins d'un an vous
en pro métiers beaucoup plus et que vous
n'avez pas pu tenir vos promesses
comment vous faire confiance aujourd'hui
quand les soignants sont à bout et que
le ségur de la santé a changé si peu de
choses les mesures que vous prenez
aujourd'hui sont nécessaires
nous regrettons qu'elle arrive trop tard
et que votre propre estimation sanitaire
empêche de continuer une politique
territorialisée que vous avez mis bien
du temps à mettre en place malgré les
demandes des élus locaux avoir laissé
les écoles ouvertes est effectivement
une fierté pour notre pays
nous regrettons qu'il fallait fermer
aujourd'hui sans que les tests
salivaires été livrées que la continuité
pédagogique puisse être facilitée
facilitée par des investissements qui
auraient permis de surmonter la
précarité numérique
de nombreux élèves nous l'avions proposé
vous ne l'avez pas fait aujourd'hui il
faut il faut mais ces prêts ministre
avant le 26 avril pour certains ou le 3
mai pour d'autres il faut vacciner le
million deux cent mille enseignants et
encadrants dans les écoles collèges et
lycées de notre pays
par ailleurs sur un autre sujet le
ruissellement de la dette publique sert
d'amortisseur économique et social nous
avons soutenu vos décisions
mais comment aller plus loin alors que
la crise révèl exacerbe les inégalités
et que vous n'entendez pas nos
propositions statut les travailleurs
fera précaire fractures numériques
éducatives aide alimentaire situation
des étudiants les plus fragiles nous
avons demandé de prévenir le risque
d'accroître la situation de précarité de
pauvreté le rsa 2 pour les moins de 25
ans rejeter le débat sur les statuts des
travailleurs plateforme rejetée pour
éviter d'accroître encore la précarité
les inégalités nous avons proposé des
solidarités fiscales nouvelles c'est
vrai des fonds de soutien des
orientations ciblées pour le plan de
relance en faveur des ménages les plus
fragilisés
quand nous proposons une réévaluation
des aides au logement et la suppression
de la réforme de ces mêmes aides qui
pénalise notamment les jeunes qui
entrent sur le marché du travail
vous nous répondez relance de la réforme
de l'assurance chômage
nous avons fait des propositions pour
préserver l'activité locale de proximité
en demandant un traitement différencié
une meilleure concertation avec les élus
locaux pour pallier le manque de
confiance des commerçants dans les aides
de l'état
rien n'a changé l'économie de proximité
de être mieux identifiée comme une
priorité de la relance rien n'a été
retenu par votre gouvernement pour ne
pas confiner la démocratie monsieur le
premier ministre
on vous l'avait évoqué à la fin de votre
discours nous avons également proposé à
de multiples reprises des mesures qui
permettent la tenue des scrutins
départementaux et régionaux dans de
meilleures conditions
mesures recommandées d'ailleurs dans le
rapport du conseil scientifique
vous n'avez pas voulu les reprendre je
le regrette ce premier ministre
en conclusion vous avez voulu freiner
ça n'a fait qu'accélérer vous avez voulu
freiner pour ne pas enfermer
il vous devez maintenant enfermée pour
freiner alors que le train de lakovic 19
et à pleine vitesse quarante à cinquante
mille cas par jour
votre gestion de la crise est un jour
sans fin pour la france les français ne
sont pas résilient monsieur le premier
ministre
ils sont aujourd'hui résignés les
français attendent autre chose
l'annnonce de la lumière au bout du
tunnel tellement invoqué nous interroge
sur la crédibilité de votre stratégie
est peut-être encore plus sur celle de
votre stratèges vous avez accepté que
nous vivions avec le virus alors que
nous aurions dû nous donner comme
objectif de l'éradiquer au plus vite
face à cette parodie politique face à
cette mascarade de démocratie face à ce
simulacre de concertation
nous avons décidé de ne pas les faire
d'être des faire valoir de votre
exécutif ne disposant pas du pouvoir de
censure au sénat le groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains ne
participera pas au vote
suite à cette déclaration 50-1 de la
constitution mais je suis monsieur
collision
[Applaudissements]
je vais donner pour la réunion de
ministres hâtive des sénateurs de
figurant sur la liste d'aucun groupe
la parole pour 3 minutes à monsieur
stéphane ravier de la parole sur
collègue monsieur monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre
hier soir le président croit qu'on fait
c'est ce que les français savait déjà et
depuis longtemps pour l'avoir subi les
conséquences graves à savoir qu'il avait
commis des erreurs
le problème voyez vous monsieur le
premier ministre c'est que vous en com
était encore et leurs conséquences ne
seront pas moins importante que les
précédentes notamment en matière de
promesses non tenues sur la création de
lits en réanimation
nous avons également entendu dire hier
soir que l'irresponsabilité de
quelques-uns ne devait pas miner les
efforts de tous les français seraient
ils encore montré du doigt ou le
président parle est il tout simplement
de votre gouvernement
face à l'offensive du variant anglais
toutes ces nouvelles mesures
liberticides sont les conséquences
directes du waterloo de la vaccination
qui marque la déroute de votre
gouvernement
car à l'image de grouchy alors que nous
attendons votre intervention salvatrice
vous êtes désespérément aux fraises
monsieur le premier ministre
mais à waterloo les chefs étaient en
première ligne
vous vous êtes en retrait en retard et
chaque jour la bataille de la vie est
perdu pour des dizaines pour les
centaines de leurs compatriotes
vous n'avez qu'un horizon à offrir notre
peuple promettre des lendemains qui
enferme nous annonce condamne les
étudiants et les plus jeunes à la
détresse des ouvriers à rester exposés
des indépendants les commerces de
proximité dont il est scientifiquement
reconnu qu'il ne constitue nullement un
lieu de contamination a fermé
définitivement pour la mère ou le père
qui va pouvoir télétravail et il devra
en même temps faire la classe à son voir
à ses enfants
on lui souhaite beaucoup de courage et
d'abnégation la dette abyssale à se
transformer en trou noir qu'à votre
confinement coûte à la france selon
bercy
365 millions d'euros par jour nos
compatriotes condamnée est tributaire
d'un calendrier de la vaccination très
incertain en raison entre autres de
votre puccino phobie qui vous pousse
encore
refuser le vaccin russe que les
allemands et les italiens ne se prive
pas de commander par millions et que
dire sur l'absence totale heureux j'ai
même de tout traitement qui permettrait
de contenir la flambée d'hospitalisation
je pense au traitement du professeur à
août à marseille un traitement qui avait
pour seul tort non pas d'être dangereux
mais de soigner quasiment gratuitement
un véritable cauchemar
un virus un empêcheur de se goinfrer en
rond pour les grands laboratoires
le professeur raoul n'a été banni en
même temps que son traitement dont
nombre d'élus marseillais et
personnalités de haut rang ont pu
bénéficier tout cela est il le résultat
de votre incompétence ou d'une véritable
stratégie car on en vient à croire
monsieur le premier ministre que ces
décisions vous conviennent le
confinement comme l'état d'urgence sont
une solution de facilité pour ne pas
régler les problèmes structurels de
l'hôpital de la recherche de l'industrie
de la souveraineté gage de la liberté de
décision en s'étendant fermement tout
azimut la vérité nous rend libres et la
vérité veut que le retour
la résurrection cheese aux dires de nos
libertés notamment ceni pour dimanche
ni pour lundi ni pour les semaines à
venir je ne serais donc conscient des 4
quant à moi cet enfer économique social
et autoritaire dans lequel vous
souhaitez enfermé le pays un mois de
plus merci je donnais maintenant la
parole à notre collègue le président
bruno retailleau
[Applaudissements]
je lui monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres mesdames messieurs chers
collègues
une fois de plus la vague est monté une
fois de plus l'hôpital est submergé une
fois de plus le président a parlé une
fois de plus le parlement est prise en
otage et une fois de plus pour la
troisième fois la france et reconfigure
monsieur le premier ministre ont
quelques instants vous allez nous
demander de voter mais c'est un vote
pour rien parce que c'est un vote sur
rien vous allez nous demander de voter
sur des annonces qui ont déjà été faites
vous allez nous demander de voter sur
des mesures à prendre qui ont déjà été
prises
oui hervé marseille et raison nous avons
l'électricité la télévision et nous
avons effectivement regarder c'est à
nancy hier télévision mais à quoi bon
voter si tout est décidé et il y un
paradoxe parce que c'est trop facile de
vouloir nous faire voter quand tout est
décidé et lorsqu on aurait aimé avoir
des votes nous le refuser souvenez vous
c'était au moment du débat pour une
reconduction d'état d'urgence et le
parlement propose est ici le sénat un
vote
lorsqu'il fallait prorogée d'un mois
le confinement c'était normal c'était un
contrôle démocratique et vous nous aviez
refusé ce vote monsieur prévu notre
ministre de la santé nous l'avait
refusée pour notre bien puisque il nous
avait dit à l'époque
c'est pour empêcher l'embolie des
chambres merci pour sa sollicitude et
c'est là que le vote aurait pu être
utile
en réalité je pense que quand je parlais
de prise d'otage du parlement vous
souhaiter que le parlement cet
après-midi le sénat soit une sorte de
faire valoir et bien le sénat mes chers
collègues ce n'est pas le faire valoir
de l'exécutif ou du président de la
république et vous n'êtes pas
et vous n'êtes pas et nous ne sommes pas
des greffiers appliqué du verdict de
jupiter c'est une évidence la vème
république ce n'est pas le président
parle à la télé et le jour d'après le
parlement s'exécute dans l'hémicycle ça
n'est pas ça la vème république
je voudrais je voudrais avec de nombreux
collègues et compris président de groupe
partagez ce que nous avons sur le coeur
vous disposez avec votre gouvernement de
pouvoir extrêmement étendue très très
étendue la contrepartie de ces pouvoirs
immenses
ce serait de veiller au contrôle
démocratique et notamment parlementaire
et pour autant vous vous ingénié
méticuleusement à marginaliser le
parlement vous avez recours aux
ordonnances depuis le début du mandat
des miles macron par le vote mais celui
des mâles macron 298 ordonnance vous
allez me dire oui mais c'est plus rapide
non c'est plus long il faut nous l'avons
démontré ici 436 jours pour une
ordonnance et il faut de 135 jours pour
la loi la loi est plus rapide quelle est
la différence
ce n'est pas la vitesse la différence si
le contrôle du parlement pas là
le recours aux ordonnances cours le
recours bien entendu au conseil de
défense à l'opacité des conseils de
défense
le recours aux procédures législatives
expéditive tous les textes sauf la
bioéthique tous sur la procédure
accélérée parce que le temps du
parlement et un temps perdu encore une
fois et puis la floraison de ces comités
théodule eh bien je pense qu'on ne peut
pas se réjouir même pour vous même pour
l'exécutif je vous mets en garde
parce que la démocratie c'est aussi des
contre-pouvoirs et je pense que c'est
une illusion dangereuse que le président
de la république conforte les français
dans cette croyance naïve d'un homme
seul capable de tout capable de tout
prendre en charge
parce que lorsqu'il y as défaillances
dans la prise en charge et que
parallèlement les mécanismes
démocratiques parlementaires ne sont
plus au rendez vous qu'est-ce qui se
passe
la nature elle a horreur du vide dans ce
face à face dans cette libéralisation de
la politique dans la suppression de tous
les intermédiaires y compris pour le
parlement qu'est ce qui se passe la
nature a horreur du vide il ya d'autres
mécanismes qui se met en place
la démocratie c'est rendre des comptes
et aux heures les plus graves notamment
première guerre mondiale
relisez votre histoire cette démocratie
n'a pas été un
obstacle à la gestion d'une crise énorme
elle était une ressource
quelle source et mécanismes qui se met
en place ce sont les réseaux sociaux où
chacun peut pour un temps vouloir
devenir un procureur à fouquier tinville
vous le savez bien
mais quand on veut le face à face au
peuple on risque cela un précédente
intervenants le disait il ya quelques
minutes
et quelle est l'autre mécanisme qui se
met en place
puisque la responsabilité démocratique
devant le parlement est insuffisant
c'est que les ministres sont appelés à
la barre et je le désapprouve cette
judiciarisation comme j'ai désapprouvé
des réquisitions à 6 heures du matin
d'un ministre de la santé qu'à autre
chose à faire évidemment je vous renvoie
la sollicitude dont nous avez rendus sur
l'embolie mshare le ministre de la santé
et cette judiciarisation non mais cette
judiciaire dit mais vous si on est au
coeur du mécanisme c'est le produit
serait coûté mois un instant parce que
c'est important
au moment où nous en sommes dans notre
démocratie cette justice irisation elle
encourage la bureaucratisation pourquoi
parce que quand on fait un protocole
vous avez tous les niveaux fischer le
risque pénal et qui vous évidemment le
parapluie tout grand judiciarisation
égale bien entendu toujours plus de
bureaucratisation voilà ce que je veux
vous dire et c'est important vous
l'entendiez alors vous avez eue nous
vous avons confié d'ailleurs des
pouvoirs très étendus
mais quand avez vous fait pour quel
résultat devrait prendre deux exemples
dont d'autres collègues ont déjà parlé
les lits de réanimation c'est important
puisque c'est ce qui vous permet de
piloter en tout cas les mesures de
freinage et sa de ce point de vue on le
comprend et puis la vaccination
qu'avez vous fait de ses pouvoirs
étendus énorme pour ce qui concerne les
lits de réanimation j'ai écouté comme
tant d'autres prisons de république j'ai
entendu comme le 28 octobre dernier
avant le second le 2e m des recours
finement le chiffre de dix mille lits
c'était le même chiffré hier donc il ya
un problème ou la promesse ou la
promesse du 28 octobre
était une tromperie ou alors si elle
n'était pas une tromperie c'est
simplement que l'engagement ne s'est pas
réalisé puisqu'on est toujours à ses dix
mille lits et ses 10 millions ne les a
pas puisque vous savez très bien que
cela découle de déprogrammation la
déprogrammation c'est la perte de chance
pour ce qui devait être opéré qui ne le
seront pas je discutais avec plusieurs
chefs de service de grands hôpitaux
parisiens
ces derniers jours eh bien il me disait
tout ce qu' il faut pratiquement le
personnel de deux blocs opératoires pour
créer un lit de réanimation c'est énorme
certains disent même que lorsque vous
soigner un patient pour une quinzaine de
jours qu vide
c'est sans doute 150 à peu près personne
patients qui devait être opéré et et qui
devront avoir leur opération repoussé ce
sont des pertes de chance pourquoi
est-ce qu'on n'a rien fait pourquoi
j'avais entendu présent république dire
parler du chiffre de 7000 personnels
soignants infirmiers infirmières et est
aussi médecin qui aurait été soignés
mais où sont ils
où est la réserve sanitaire sur le
terrain je vous assure
pour ce que l'on connaît pour nos
départements pour nos régions
la réserve sanitaire on ne la voit pas
pourquoi en parler et cela fait un an
qu'on en parle qu'avons nous fait de ses
pouvoirs
qu'avez vous fait de ses pouvoirs
énormes qui vous ont été confiées et sur
la vaccination
je vous ai entendu mois ci au mois de
décembre parler d'un chiffre mi avril
c'était 14 millions je crois est
désormais pour la mi mars
et désormais c'est 10 millions pour la
mi-avril mais parce que monsieur le
ministre premier ministre il ya une
valse des chiffres il ya une valse du
calendrier que y'a pas un français ici
retrouve je vous assure je vous assure
tellement il ya eu de changement de pied
et vous allez dire très bien c'est
l'europe
j'ai entendu j'ai entendu un haut
responsable allemand d'ailleurs il ya
quinze jours me répondent oui mais mieux
vaut vacciner lentement mais vacciner
dans un cadre européen
ça c'est l'idéologie et ça ça n'est pas
entendable par nos compatriotes c'est
vous qui êtes en charge de la protection
des français de la nation française
aucun cas
ces européens ne fera pour le peuple
français ce que un élu du peuple peut
faire pour protéger les français
ça me paraît une évidence évidemment
donc ce pouvoir quand vous a confiée
vous l'avez exercer mais pour peu de
résultats j'entendais la fameuse phrase
quand je me regarde et quand je me
compare donc quand on se compare mes
chers amis on se désole plus tôt nous
sommes en matière de vaccination au 51e
rang ça veut dire qu'on fait moins bien
que le chili cole maroc que la serbie
peut la hongrie que tant d'autres pays
l'allemagne et à un peu plus de soixante
quinze mille morts avec 82 millions
d'habitants nous nous allons arriver à
cent mille morts et chacun d'entre nous
a une pensée pour ceux qui sont plus là
pour leurs familles qui souffrent
toujours
mais c'est ça les résultats c'est à cela
qu'on doit juger une politique même si
je sais que les circonstances sont
difficiles
évidemment et je le dis ici aujourd'hui
je le répète à cette tribune
voilà ce que nous attendons nous
attendons une efficacité mais je pense
qu'on ne peut pas toujours pointé la
responsabilité de la technocratie de la
bureaucratie
il ya eu dès le départ un manque de
volonté au plus haut niveau de l'état
au même moment alors évidemment je vais
parler de monsieur tron en mai il dit je
suis confiant pour payer un vaccin d'ici
la fin de l'année
quelques jours après le prénom d'un
public français lui répond personne de
sérieux personne de sérieux ne me dis
que nous disposerons d'un vaccin à la
fin d'année donc quand nous sommes dans
cette organisation hyper
présidentialiser hyper centralisé et que
la tête ne crois pas en l'occurrence à
cette possibilité de disposer des
vaccins il ne met pas en tension toute
la chaîne de commandement et faut pas
s'étonner ensuite qui est diluée
la vérité elle est là c'est d'abord un
manque de volonté politique manque de
volonté politique et manque de stratégie
il ya deux stratégies gagnantes dans le
monde on l'a vu la stratégie des
démocraties asiatique le zéro co vide on
n'a pas pu le faire
mango d'efficacité du traçage manque
d'efficacité pour isolement mais eu
moins de 20000 morts et puis il ya une
autre stratégie gagnante c'est la
vaccination de peace avait loupé la
première marche dans la gestion de
l'épidémie
c'est le royaume uni c'est les états
unis et d'autres c'est la vaccination
rapide mais massive et nous n'avons eu
ni l'une ni l'autre des deux stratégies
nous avons eu certes à paris la
bureaucratie ajouté à la technocratie
bruxelloise et voilà le trou de souris
des mails macron s'est transformée pour
beaucoup de français en souricière mes
chers amis voilà
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui ce que
veulent les français c'est qu' on puisse
leur donner des preuves de l'efficacité
et qu'on reconstitue l'antidote qui est
la confiance la confiance vous la
reconstituer à trois conditions la
première c'est l'efficacité
j'en parlais il ya quelques instants
s'il faut commander des vaccins en
dehors de la procédure européenne faite
le l'ambassadeur d'allemagne nous a ici
au sénat c'est dans un compte-rendu
confirmé qu'il y avait eu la commande de
30 millions de fans the hand or il n'y a
pas d'interdiction
faisons le pourquoi ne le ferions nous
pas bien donc l'efficacité d'abord et
arrêtons de considérer que chaque vad et
la dernière anticipons en matière de
formation en matière de lits de
réanimation
première condition à la confiance
l'efficacité deuxième condition
l'humanité je l' ai déjà dit l'autre
jour il y a eu et vous avez sans doute
vu ces témoignages de personnalités
artistiques culturelles qui témoignent
qu'ils prennent la voie des familles qui
ont été créés des très belles lettres
attention à ne pas laisser mourir dans
la solitude dans les ehpad
mais aussi derrière des portes closes de
pitau ça se ferait peut-être de moison à
mais chaque semaine nous avons des
témoignages cet aspect humain il est
déterminant et enfin il ya la lucidité
de la lucidité de reconnaître ces lignes
chacun d'entre nous avons nos limites
chacun d'entre nous monsieur le 1er mai
dans une crise le pire et c'est la
limite qui ne doit pas être franchie
c'est justement de ne pas reconnaître
ces lignes et je pense que un prison
république
même lorsqu'il et jupiter même lorsqu'il
est un expert une universelle un
d'épidémiologistes en même temps qu'un
philosophe même quand il est doté de la
plus belle intelligence il est doté
d'une pensée complexe même lui seul ne
peut rien seul c'est absolument une
évidence donc je crois que les
institutions représentatives de notre
démocratie doivent être
respectez ne fait pas du sénat ou de
l'assemblée nationale un théâtre
d'ombrés ce lieu
ce lieu d'une fausse concertation ce
lieu d'un simulacre de décision nous
allons comme d'autres ne pas participer
au vote
ce geste politique ce n'est pas un
mouvement de mauvaise humeur ce n'est
pas un caprice c'est simplement un
message
la démocratie représentative et chers
amis c'est l'assurance pour tous les
français quel qu'il soit quelles que
soient leurs sentiments politiques c'est
l'assurance que le sort de tous ne
repose pas dans les mains d'un seul
voilà ce qu'est la démocratie voilà
pourquoi la démocratie a été inventé
alors oui il nous faut reconstruire
ensemble monsieur le premier ministre et
nous sommes disponibles la confiance
mais la confiance par la preuve par
l'efficacité et j'ose espérer que cette
nuit sans fin aura une home une aube
nouvelle
et comme l'a dit le président de
république que cette eau ce sera une ode
un joli mois de mai vous n'en avez pas
parlé je les entends dû en parler
j'espère que vous croyez à cette
promesse présidentielle d'ailleurs si
vous croyez à ce que en mai les choses
aillent mieux
en mai c'est à dire que les bars les
restaurants rouvre pourquoi nous ferions
nous pas si il n'y avait plus d'élection
ce serait donc l'échec de la promesse du
président république d'hier soir en tout
cas nous voulons une nouvelle espérance
et je pense que c'est en abandonnant les
vieux démons
mais c'est surtout en écoutant le
parlement et c'est surtout en redonnant
confiance aux français que vous y
parviendrez merci merci
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président
je vais maintenant donner la parole au
président claude malhuret pour le groupe
les indépendants une république et
territoires et le président malgré à 8
minutes
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues depuis l'annnonce inespérée de
vaccins découvert en quelques mois
seulement par des chercheurs que nous ne
remercierons jamais assez
la course est lancée entre l'acquisition
de l'immunité collective qui nous
sauvera de la pandémie et la
discimination des nouveau variant du
virus qui signerait notre défaite
cette équation à deux inconnues est une
horde ali pour le gouvernement comme
pour les français parce qu'elle se
complique de deux paramètres qui en font
les frais yable complexité le premier
est le retentissement immédiat de toutes
mesures sanitaires sur l'économie du
pays qui dans le cas extrême d'un
confinement total s'écroule aussitôt
nous l'avons vécu le deuxième et le
désastre psychique causée par une crise
interminable pour tous nos concitoyens
dont beaucoup sont désormais au bord de
l'effondrement
ou tout au moins de l'épuisement
jamais la situation n'a été aussi
tendues et c'est pourquoi même si nous
entrevoyons la lumière au bout du tunnel
nous sentons tous que les semaines qui
viennent seront cruciales
c'est sans doute la raison pour laquelle
la décision du président de la
république de ne par confiner en janvier
dernier mais de prendre des mesures
graduelles segmentant pour la première
fois des injonctions scientifique a été
très majoritairement approuvée par les
français
malgré ce qu'ils ont souligné les
risques les insuffisances ou l'aspect
d'un pari hasardeux
je le dis clairement je fais partie avec
beaucoup d'autres ici de ceux qui ont
approuvé cette stratégie et je ne peux
donc aujourd'hui critiqué le président
de la république en demandant s'il
n'aurait pas dû prendre il ya deux mois
et décisions qu'il prend ce jour voire
des décisions plus radicales encore ce
serait oublier aussi que depuis des mois
les enfants sont allés à l'école que les
entreprises ont tourné et que la plupart
des français on peut mener une vie
presque normale
c'est oublier aussi que du fait des
nouveaux variants la certitude d'une
efficacité absolue d'un confinement
n'était pas évidente
contrairement au premier avec des
mesures plus radicales que les nôtres
depuis deux mois
l'allemagne est aujourd'hui quasiment au
même nombre de décès quotidiens que nous
l'italie presque au double
le même dilemme se pose aujourd'hui avec
une intensité décuplée par des courbes
qui remonte par des critiques qui fusent
pas nouveau et enfin et peut-être
surtout par les pressions pour des
mesures radicales d'une partie du corps
médical peut être déçu qu'on ne suivent
plus et prescriptions à la lettre loin
de moi de nier les difficultés extrêmes
et qui s'aggrave rond dans les jours qui
viennent des services de soins intensifs
loin de moi l'idée de vouloir minimiser
le dévouement inlassable des soignants
dont beaucoup sont eux aussi au bord de
l'épuisement
mais il faut rendre à césar ce qui est à
césar et aux politiques ses prérogatives
et la première est la responsabilité de
juger des moyens de tenir dans
l'adversité et d'en juger
en prenant en compte les préoccupations
les possibilités les capacités de
résistance ou les cauchemars de tous les
français en ayant à l'esprit le choix en
ayant à l'esprit que le choix est
rarement entre une bonne et une mauvaise
solution
mais entre une mauvaise solution et une
pire encore ce choix est d'autant plus
difficile que les médecins eux mêmes
sont partagés il suffit de regarder les
plateaux de télévision de jour comme de
nuit
pour s'en convaincre ces derniers jours
41 médecins de l'ap-hp expliqué dans une
tribune au monde je crois nous n'avons
jamais connu une telle situation
même durant les pires attentats de ces
dernières années tribune à laquelle le
président de l'association des médecins
urgentistes de france répondait le
lendemain
pour l'instant ce n'est pas la bérézina
faire croire que l'on va sélectionner et
trier les malades c'est totalement fou
un patron de la pitié salpêtrière appelé
avant-hier à la fermeture immédiate des
écoles la société française de pédiatrie
lui répondait le lendemain il faut tout
faire pour éviter de fermer les écoles
c'est dans ce contexte que le président
de la république a dû prendre une
décision que j'imagine déchirant camper
sur des mesures dont il apparaît
désormais qu'elles ne suffisent plus à
réduire l'épidémie
c'était la certitude de perdre la course
de vitesse contre le virus reconfirmer
totalement c'était une capitulation
c'était aussi le risque d'une révolte
d'une partie de nos concitoyens et nous
le voyons tous dans nos départements
l'exécutif a choisi l'accentuation des
mesures de freinage plus tôt que le
retour à un confinement strict étendre à
l'ensemble dû territoire métropolitain
les mesures qui prévalait déjà dans les
territoires les plus touchés et
prolonger les vacances scolaires de 15
jours tout en laissant ouvertes les
crèches et le primaire ces mesures
seront sans doute douloureusement
ressenti dans des régions qui pouvait se
sentir à l'abri mais qui en réalité
chaque jour nous le démontre un peu plus
ne le sont pas par des commerçants déjà
durement éprouvée et par des parents
épuisés se demandant comment ils
pourront concilier profession et garde
des enfants
elles seront en réalité ressentie
douloureusement partout mais je ne vois
guère d'alternative
la clé de notre avenir ce sont désormais
les vaccins et surtout la campagne pour
les délivrer le début de cette campagne
a donné lieu à beaucoup de critiques sur
sa lenteur sur la décision de s'en
remettre à l'europe sur la crainte des
rejets de la vaccination par les
français je partage pour une part ces
critiques
vous vous souvenez sans doute qu ici
même l'an dernier alors qu'on prétendait
que les français étaient vaccinaux
sceptiques
j'ai dit à plusieurs reprises qu'il
fallait aller plus vite que le principe
de précaution ruines parfois ce qu'il
prétend défendre et que ma crainte
n'était pas que les vaccins restent dans
les congélateurs
mais au contraire qu'il n'y en ait pas
assez le président dans son discours
d'hier semble avoir pris la mesure de
cet enjeu crucial
l'accélération est impérative nous
devons nous donner les moyens d'y
parvenir
le gouvernement n'a désormais d'autre
choix que de réussir le succès de la
vaccination est aujourd'hui entre les
mains de l'exécutif désormais tenus à
une obligation de résultat il sait qu'il
peut compter sur l'ensemble des élus
locaux qui ne cesse de faire la preuve
de leur dévouement et de leur efficacité
plusieurs groupes de notre assemblée ont
annoncé leur intention de ne pas
participer au vote qui conclura ce débat
je comprends leur agacement et pour
certains leur irritation la vème
république n'est pas tendre pour le
parlement et ce n'est pas la première
fois que nous nous plaignons de la façon
dont nous sommes traités par l'exécutif
mais la question qui nous est posée
aujourd'hui est d'une telle importance
pour l'avenir de nos concitoyens pour
les mois et peut-être les années qui
viennent pour notre santé notre économie
notre futur en un mot qu'il ne nous
paraît pas possible en plein milieu de
la pire crise sanitaire depuis des
années de ne pas prendre nos
responsabilités
les français ont le droit de connaître
l'opinion de leurs élus lorsque
l'essentiel est en jeu c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous participerons à ce
scrutin
c'est toujours lorsqu'on est sur le
point de réussir que la tentation de
renoncer est la plus forte
c'est toujours le dernier effort qui est
le plus douloureux c'est celui qui nous
est demandé aujourd'hui mais il est pour
la première fois accompagné d'un message
d'espoir crédible qui permet de fixer
des échéances précises et annoncer cette
crise est une épreuve mais ce n'est
qu'une épreuve et l'humanité en a
surmonté de bien plus grave dans
quelques mois grâce au vaccin grâce à
notre respect des règles
grâce à notre solidarité 2021 sera
l'année où nous surmonterons à notre
tour l'épreuve qui nous est assignée je
vous remercie
merci monsieur le président
donne la parole maintenant au président
guillaume gontard pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité et territoires il
a huit minutes
sur trois ans vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
un an de pandémie et bientôt cent mille
morts en france près de 3 millions dans
le monde
un an de pandémie et 4,6 millions de
malades
un an de pandémie et un personnel
soignant à bout de souffle un an de
pandémie et des inégalités sociales qui
explosent un an de pandémie et plus de
10 millions de pauvres dans notre pays
un an de pandémie une entreprise sur
trois mené cette faillite malgré les
aides gouvernementales
un an de pandémie et de détresse
psychologique
un an de pandémie et de jeunesse aux
abois un an pandémie et vie sociale et
culturelle sous cloche
un an de pandémie et des perspectives
toujours aussi incertaine
le bilan sanitaire social et économique
du commis 19 et dramatique et ses
conséquences se feront ressentir pendant
des années ce bilan n'est pas celui du
gouvernement
vous avez agi le plus souvent du mieux
que vous pouviez et il est prétentieux
et malvenue d'expliquer que nous aurions
fait beaucoup mieux mais il n'est pas
non plus possible de vous exonérer de
votre responsabilité ni surtout de celle
du président de la république monsieur
le premier ministre je relisais mon
propos lors du débat organisé dans de
pareilles circonstances le 20 au 29
octobre dernier et cette lecture m'a
désespéré
rien n'a changé depuis un an rien n'a
changé depuis cinq mois
jupiter l'épidémiologiste jupiter leroy
traumat urgent jupiter le maître des
horloges décide de tout tout seul et
vous venez ensuite faire le service
après vente devant nous laperne la
pertinence de l'exercice
interroge du coup puisque nous sommes là
vous ne m'en voudrez pas de reprendre
quelques propos de l'intervention du 29
octobre
ils sont et je déplore toujours voir
davantage d'une vibrante actualité vous
n'avez pas su construire l'union
nationale indispensable à la période
rien n'a changé le président continue
vainement de l'invoquer comme on crie
dans le vent il aurait été opportun et
intelligent d'associer la représentation
nationale aux décisions permettant de
faire face à la situation sanitaire
économique et social tout en protégeant
les libertés individuelles
c'est comme cela que fonctionne une
démocratie normale mais si on avait
encore un doute sur le fait que la vème
république n'était pas une démocratie
normale
le voilà de lever depuis un an le
parlement aurait dû retrouver toute sa
place et c'était votre intérêt notre
intérêt collectif d'associer réellement
l'opposition aux prises de décision
encore moins que d'habitude
l'exécutif ne peut avoir raison tout
seul
la complexité du défi auquel nous
faisons face aurait nécessité et
nécessitent toujours de s'appuyer sur
l'intelligence et la responsabilité
collective des élus du peuple plutôt que
sur l'intelligence d'un seul homme
si supérieur soit elles responsables
devant personne
selon notre bancal constitution en la
matière vous auriez également dû
associer beaucoup plus et traitements
les élus locaux
hélas la consultation des territoires au
préalable de décision d'ampleur
nationale comme celle que vous présentez
aujourd'hui et toujours inexistantes
quand les élus sont responsables et de
bonne composition à votre endroit
je pense par exemple au maire de lyon
vos ministres les récompenses avec des
accusations fallacieuses et des
polémiques médiocres au lieu de garder
leur temps et leur énergie et on a
besoin à la résolution de la crise alors
la gouvernance demeurent solitaire et
erratique ce manque total de visibilité
affaiblit chaque jour davantage
l'acceptabilité des mesures qui sont
prises et leur efficacité
c'est un cercle vicieux qui nous dessert
tous et toutes collectivement en un an
vous n'avez jamais été capable de donner
de la visibilité aux françaises et aux
français
certes la situation est instable est
difficilement prévisible mais d'autres
pays ont fait beaucoup mieux
je pense notamment à l'afrique du sud
pays pourtant très durement touchée par
le virus qui a pris le temps d'élaborer
un mode de gouvernance intéressant en
lien avec le parlement le gouvernant a
pris en place un barème à cinq niveaux
d' alerte à la manière de notre barème
vigipirate à chaque niveau correspond
progressivement un certain nombre de
mesures de distance à sion et de
restriction de la liberté de mouvement
et d'activités le changement niveau et
active
et par le gouvernement sur la base de
critères objectifs circulation du virus
nombre de décès niveau d'occupation des
hôpitaux jeu premier ministre qu'est ce
qui empêche le gouvernement de mettre en
place un tel dispositif qui permettrait
de donner de la visibilité aux
françaises et aux français aux élus
locaux et aux entreprises qui
permettrait de renforcer l'acceptabilité
des mesures et de soulager notre
démocratie
enfin qu'est ce qui empêche également de
demander à l'om c'est comme l'a
d'ailleurs fait aussi l'afrique du sud
et l'inde
la levée des brevets sur les vaccins car
pour vacciner il faut des vaccins et il
faut en produire ce constat lé
longuement posé ses désabusé sans grand
espoir que vous entendiez mon message
que je vais néanmoins vous formuler
quelques demandes pour accompagner les
mesures que vous présentez ce ce cet
après midi qu dont je conteste pas faute
d'alternative le bien fondé il faut
premièrement renforcer les moyens de
l'hôpital le ségur de la santé est
insuffisant les soignants sont exemple
on peine à recruter des infirmières et
des infirmiers
il faut les récompenser davantage pour
les efforts de la période et les
revaloriser de manière pérenne est
significative
il faut aussi renforcer les moyens
matériels et humains
le président promettait jusqu'à douze
mille lits de réanimation en octobre
nous en sommes
selon ses dires à 7000 à lyon à bord
dont les hôpitaux militaires ferment
alors qu'ils auraient pu accueillir des
malades
monsieur le ministre entendait enfin la
lassitude et l'expert et l'exaspération
des soignants senti le bilan de la
pandémie serait catastrophique
comment cette crise n'a pas encore
débouché sur un plan marshall de
l'hôpital public
notre pain est plus que temps de prendre
des mesures d'urgence sociale digne de
ce nom
nous avons déjà des moindres tard 10
millions de pauvres des étudiants qui
vont à la soupe populaire
votre dogmatisme néolibéral est
incompréhensible
il faut abroger la réforme de
l'assurance chômage augmente et les
minima sociaux
automatiser leurs versements élargir sa
a été rappelé leur rsa aux moins de 25
ans rétablir les contrats aidés aider
les associations et tendre demain vers
un revenu universel
nous vous demandons également une
vigilance accrue sur tous les publics
exposée par le confinement les personnes
seules les personnes psychologiquement
fragile les victimes de violence
conjugale et tout particulièrement les
femmes vous fermer les écoles un mois le
temps des vacances de pâques nous
faisions cette proposition la semaine
derière ici même lors des questions au
gouvernement
nous sommes aujourd'hui soulagé que
l'évidence et finit par s'imposer
le retard de la victimation explique en
partie cette situation et les personnels
scolaires doivent devenir un public
prioritaire le manque de moyens
notamment humains les difficultés
trouver les remplacements l'expliquent
aussi hier le président évoqué le combat
du siècle s'agissant du décrochage
scolaire et des retards d'apprentissage
de notre jeunesse
espérons que pour une fois il ne s'agit
pas de propos incantatoire dont il
attend l'habitude car pour notre école
il faut des moyens considérables pour
dédoubler les classes recruter et
revaloriser les enseignants pour
financer cet effort national sans
précédent les hauts revenus doivent être
mis à contribution
enfermé dans votre idéologie vous vous
irez fusé depuis le printemps dernier
pourtant c'est indispensable d'un point
de vue financier comme d'un point de vue
moral pour garantir l'unité du pays
il faut mettre en place une contribution
exceptionnelle sur les hauts revenus
dont la richesse s'accroît encore malgré
la crise il faut une autre il faut une
autre de toutes les entreprises qui ont
fait des bénéfices grâce à la crise
notamment les géants de la vente en
ligne et les grandes surfaces
monsieur le premier ministre les
écologistes ont cessé d'être constructif
durant cette crise qui nous engage
toutes et tous nous continueront à
l'être quand vous voudrez bien nous
consulté en amont
ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui et je le
regrette et vous comprendrez que nous
prenions pas pas non plus à cette
mascarade démocratique
merci merci monsieur le président la
parole maintenant au président françois
patriat pour le rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes et indépendants
ridha 8 minutes sur le président vous
avez la parole
ce président monsieur le premier
ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues au delà de
les talents d'orateur que vous avez
développé ceux qui m'ont précédé
quand j'entends la dureté de certains
propos la véhémence de certaines
attaques
les sharks asthme facile les procès sans
appel au delà de tout ça et que
j'intéresse certains d'entre vous ils ne
répondent c'est le jeu est ce que vous
croyez
mes chers collègues que le moment que
nous vivons est un moment de jeu ça fait
un an que l'inquiétude du coc u19 frappe
l'ensemble des pays du monde
bouleversant les échanges endeuillant
les familles transformons nos vies
chacun d'entre nous a vécu dans sa ville
dans son entourage dans son intimité le
doute l'éloignement la solitude et
parfois le décès un an
pour mieux comprendre ce virus nouveau
c'est désormais le cas un an pour
s'armer face à lui pour lutter chacun du
mois par mois contre l'évolution de la
maladie
avec mon futur la vaccination en
première ligne et un an
nous devons tous prendre conscience des
décisions cruciales
allez pour objectif d' agir en
responsabilité et pour nous tous de
tenir ensemble
la question qui nous est posée
aujourd'hui après l'assemblée nationale
et d'apporter ou non notre adhésion aux
mesures prises par le chef de l'état et
par le gouvernement j'entends parler de
fausse concertation de mise en eux
écoutez je te veux dire ici j'ai
participé à tous les comités de liaison
se prémunissent tu suis témoin vous le
dire je n'ai jamais entendu de la part
du président ici d'une proposition ou
l'afp revenant jamais je n'aurais les
propositions jamais jamais telle est
bien la cause la question et et dire
aujourd'hui qu'il n'y a pas eu de
consultation je pense que ces
consultations ont eu lieu et que les
décisions prises par le gouvernement
hier monsieur soumier vous le dit on été
prise après de nombreuses consultations
ir encore iran temps monsieur juillet
vous parlait d'un homme seul au pouvoir
vous tombez dans une irresponsabilité
qui vous déshonore un peu
il aura eu bien oui il y aura eu il y
aura eu bien des anathèmes bien des
mises en demeures bien des caricatures
il n'ya eu beaucoup de yaka fokon il est
facile il est facile sur un plateau de
dire fermant les écoles de dire de même
jour au tour ce serait inhumain de
confiner les français mais derrière ces
mots il existe une multitude de réalité
il existe des parents débordés des
enfants seuls face à leurs difficultés
d'autres entouré par des tuteurs en
laissant ouvertes monsieur le ministre
d'éducation en laissant ouvertes les
écoles pendant quarante deux semaines le
choix a été fait de pallier à ces
inégalités et ce fait nous excluent
aujourd'hui du drame éducatif que
l'unesco souligne aujourd'hui plutôt que
de critiquer la france tous les jours
vous seriez mieux parfois d'en saluer
les bienfaits aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
plus encore aujourd'hui plus encore
qu'il y a un an
je pense que l'humilité demeure
essentielle est-ce que nous pourrions
merci mes chers collègues de la police
où il faut chaud au coeur est ce
qu'aujourd'hui nous pourrions faire
sortir du jeu politique et des postures
binaire qui trop souvent dénature notre
débat notre rôle impose que chacun donne
aux mots soient choisis avec
responsabilité dans ces climent dans ce
climat où il est si facile de les user
comme des leçons des reproches ou des
menaces
j'entends ici qu'il y aurait d'un côté
ici ou là ceux qui critiquent ce qu'ils
savent ceux qui prédisent ce qu'ils
écoutent qu'il ne décide jamais et de
l'autre ceux qui ignorent ce qui sont
arrogants ceux qui ne consultent pas
ceux qui n'entendent pas et qui décide
et dans les décisions sont toujours
contestées
dans ce jeu là ne fait pas avancer
aujourd'hui notre pays et avancer la
lutte contre nous contre le virus je
pense que vous ne pense que nous pouvons
sortir de ce jeu parce que l'expérience
de cette année deux drames
d'épidémiologique nous a apporté un
certain nombre d'enseignements
quels sont ils d'abord parce que
l'évolution de l'épidémie a toujours été
une suite de surprises d'aller à de
mauvaises surprises d'événements venant
contredire ceux qui étaient la veille
encore perçu comme une vérité chaque
mesure nouvelle est un choix un choix
difficile mais un choix nécessaire pense
que les décisions si nous le regardons
rétrospectivement ont montré leurs
effets j'entends monsieur prémunissent
par exemple la décision du chef de
l'état
il y a un en avril 2020 de rouvrir la
vie au mois de mai elle avait été
contestée compris sur ses bancs comme
étant prématurée est dangereuse elle
s'est révélée efficace juste et adaptée
elle a été salué à l'époque comme un
modèle de déconfinement que vous avez
conduit monsieur le premier ministre
on a reproché ensuite au mois d'octobre
après une décision de confiner sans
concertation alors que nous étions je
vous rappelle à 50000 potable nation par
jour à cette époque et pendant tout le
mois de novembre
j'ai entendu sur les bancs de cet
hémicycle aux questions d'actualité une
fois à vendre 1 mercredi à jeudi après
midi à mercredi après midi
cette question d'actualité de mon temps
de rouvrir les commerces de rouvrir les
librairies de rouvrir les discothèques
de douvres et les salles de gym tous à
chaque fois alors que alors matin j'ai
entendu cela alors que dans le même
temps nous peignons à descendre des
50000 que nous sommes malgré tout
arriver
vingt mille et dans le même temps vous
demandiez des mesures de liberté et vous
disais que le gouvernement était
liberticide
j'ai entendu depuis trois mois tellement
d'avis contraire ceux qui disaient qu'il
fallait continuer préventivement
c'est pourtant une méthode sûre
retailleau qui n'a pas qui n'a pas
réussi dans les p -o n'a été évoquée
le confinement préventif ça n'existe pas
ça existe quand le virus est là ça n'a
pas empêché l'allemagne d'avoir une
forte contamination de confiner
préventivement n'est pas forcément la
bonne solution
il ya ceux qui auraient voulu au
contraire laisser la france sans
coercition sans obstacle avec une
responsabilité que nous retrouvons
parfois dans certains comportements
ce qui s'est passé le week-end dernier
dans telle ou telle ville que je ne
citerai pas aujourd'hui y compris ce que
je vois au quotidien dans les métropoles
massif ou pas ne me faites pas dire
toujours que la responsabilité est
présent certains s'adonnent à des
comparaisons hasardeuses avec d'autres
pays
les bonnes mesures étant apparemment
souvent prises ailleurs cette
fascination pour l'étranger aujourd'hui
monsieur prendra tous les jours
probablement oublie-t-il de mentionner
le nombre de morts américains troisième
cause de mortalité en 2020 dans le pays
le taux de chômage atteint 14% en avril
oublie-t-il également de préciser que le
déconfinement royaume uni et réussit
alors qu'il se résume la possibilité de
se retrouver dans un parc à six
personnes
non le gouvernement ne prend pas des
demi mesures
il prend des mesures appropriées graduée
tentant à faire face à cette explosion
virale aujourd'hui qui permettra de
passer le pic dans quelques jours puis
dans quelques semaines de revenir avec
la vaccination une vie presque normale
ces taxis nation certains n'en voulez
pas vous rassemblement national bien
entendu j'ai entendu madame le pen dire
que ne se ferait jamais vacciné que
monsieur mélenchon direct non plus ne
ferai jamais vacciné la france a soumis
aussi déclarant sur le plateau pour gelé
les jeux les réentendu gelé réentendu
hier soir avec tel sénateur ici présents
dans l'hémicycle qui recommandait tous
les français d'être soigné à la
chloroquine et qui disait début janvier
on n'allait pas le prendre pour un
cobaye la nuit dans un tweet il se
reconnaîtra je rappelle les français je
rappelle les français que les français à
60% ne voulait pas se faire vacciner
début janvier
pourtant le gouvernement a tenu il avait
anticipé
il avait dans le cadre européen choisi
de produire d'acheter des vaccins et
heureusement que ce cadre a été
respectée européen
sinon je ne sais dans quelle guerre
d'achat des vaccins nous serions
aujourd'hui le rythme des vaccinations
que certains contesté a été tenue vous
avez douté
vous avez douté du million vous avez
douté du million de vaccins en janvier
nous l'avons dépassé douter des quatre
millions de personnes vaccinées en
février nous l'avons dépassé doutait des
10 millions au mois d'avril nous les
dépasserons douter des 30 millions fin
juin et nous les aurons
et vous doutez encore qui les français
puissent être vaccinés dès l'été c'est
votre responsabilité
je ne vous posera pas au moment de
prendre une décision aujourd'hui on peut
dire merci à vous au moment de prendre
une décision aujourd'hui on peut
toujours contester toutes les mesures et
j'entends bien ce que disait ce matin à
leaders de l'opposition ne faut pas
fermer les écoles ne faut pas fermer les
commerces
mais alors que faut-il faire face
addiction situation explosive
je crois que les mesures que propose le
gouvernement sont des mesures de sagesse
qu'elles pourront nous permettre de
passer les trois ou quatre semaines
difficiles qu'il reste à passer avant un
nom une embellie que la vaccination
fasse effet c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous apporterons notre soutien
aux décisions qui sont prises
j'ai beaucoup entendu parler de jupiter
aujourd'hui et bien et bien donc je
cours plus est bien en ce jour
particulier
ils ont en votant temps refusé de voter
cette à ponce pilate que je pense ne
font pas partie de ce fait là je vois là
[Musique]
ça tombe bien le vendredi mais la parole
est au président jean claude roch et
pour le rassemblement démocratique et
social européen
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président pour lui minutes si monsieur
le président monsieur pour les ministres
et ses mig et sa collègue monsieur le
président l écoute de votre création
g et soyez sûr que je le regrette la
sensation de déjà vu déjà vu car propos
sont au final dans la droite lignée des
avances du président de la république
hier soir sans surprise déjà vu depuis
l'intérieur années que ces déclarations
se suivent les petits prés prorogation
des tailleurs et un sanitaire aussi avec
de l'impression qu'ils sont devenus des
certitudes
d'abord celle d'un président la lui qui
décide
comme si la vème république avait
atteint son plafond de verre à ses
estampes érotiques
celui enfin de l'exécutif qui parle de
choix collectifs que nous avons fait sur
le drame
quel choix collectifs ait acquis été
fait le con finale de confinement leur
confinement le continuité la fermeture
des commerces que l'on fait à deal it
eur puis à 21 le rayon de 20m puis 10 km
celui concédé face
je crains monsieur le premier ministre
que nous n'ayons pas la même définition
de ce qu'est un choix collectif dans une
démocratie parlementaire
il réduit trop terne colin kanepi avant
d'être en son temps aurait nécessité que
le débat parlementaire ait lieu avant
l'allocution du président de la
république et que l'ensemble du corps
législatif soit associé étroitement à
l'ensemble des décisions prises depuis
maintenant un an
car depuis un an c'est hélas le même
schéma qui se reproduit sans qu'aucune
leçon n'ait été retenue je constate que
le président du milk a demandé aux
soignants un effort pour augmenter nos
capacités de réanimation alors qui
nécessite avant tout de plus de main
d'oeuvre
et le président s'est voulu rassurant
mais le constat est tout autre
l'épidémie a bondi la vaccination c'est
effectivement un corps trop lente et
nous payons tous le pari d'avoir
privilégié temporairement une économie
aux dépens de rebond fulgurant de la
contamination
jeudi cette ambiguïté il n'y a aucune
tension pour votre part de sauver les
polémiques inutiles mais nous avons
l'impression que le regret que
l'ensemble des mesures prononcées hier
auraient pu auraient dû être prises en
amont et que nous aurons perdu un temps
précieux sur ces mesures
je crois que nous pourrons tous partager
l'objectif initial qui était de
maintenir l'école ouverte maintenir ce
lien entre l'école de la république et
ses enfants étaient nécessaires car on
connaît les causes et calvin de l'astral
coréen éloignement prolongé de l'école
pour les élèves notamment pour ceux des
plus défavorisés d'entre eux mais si le
virus ne circule pas plus à l'écran le
cas hier il ne circule pas moi non plus
aussi la fermeture avancée était
inévitable face à cela la scène balance
duncan très drôle arthur était
insuffisant oui vous avez avancé droit
en charge partielle programme des
français qui ne pourraient pas qu'ils ne
pourraient pas de télé travailler et ils
sont nombreux notamment dans les
territoires ruraux
mais pensez vous qu'ils soient et aurait
été travaillé avec les enfants à la
maison
il faut aller plus loin en proposant des
alternatives de carn en prenant plus
largement en compte des 8 millions de
familles monoparentales de notre pays il
faut enfin se servir de ces trois
semaines de fermeture pour vacciner
prioritairement les professeurs
encadrants ce qui permettra de concilier
une rupture ouverte les classes et la
foire 15 la protection sanitaire que
nous devons à nos équipes éducatives sur
la vaccination toujours on ne peut que
souscrire vacciner l'action matinée et à
volonté et la volonté de voir l'ensemble
de la population matinée au plus tôt
mais là encore ne peut que regretter des
atermoiements concernant la stratégie
vaccinale a tellement d'abord sera comme
en européenne plus que timide
enterrement ensuite seul haut rhinois
qui nations les plus âgés des patients à
risque notamment voir enfin quant à
l'utilisation du vaccin rascol
cas où sa suppression temporaire alors
même que le ps demandé la poursuite sans
prescription attaques ce qu'a créé la
défiance est nourrie et scepticisme
résultat le récent courait à juger et je
cite que le rythme de vaccination en
europe était inacceptable
à ce titre même si nous sommes des
européens convaincus
il nous faut militer pour la levée des
brevets concernant les vaccins et
adapter notre appareil productif afin
d'avoir la maîtrise des destins
vaccinale en somme il faut agir plutôt
que réagir pour atteindre nos objectifs
de sortie les prises concernant
l'extension des mesures sanitaires à
l'ensemble des territoires
métropolitains et la règle et 10 km de
30 kilomètres je crains que son
application soit difficile au matériel
d'avoir dans les zones rurales ou
nombreux commerces de services publics
ou même de santé ne se situe pas dans
son cercle
il mettra automatiquement nombre de
concitoyens hors la loi ensuite comment
vérifier l'adresse lorsque celle ci
n'est pas la même que celle du papier
d'identité et lorsque l'adresse aimerez
et la borne comment être sûr que le
cercle et 10 km est bien respecté les
rênes de police cannan ne sont pas dotés
de dca m vous le savez ce rayon de 10 km
soit aussi difficilement respectable
zones urbaines où l'on peut davantage de
penser que les services essentiels sont
importants pour limiter le besoin de
s'aérer n'en est pas moins que plus
grand d'autant que tout le monde n'a pas
sale d'avoir une résidence secondaire ou
un pied-à-terre à la mer à la montagne
ou à la campagne
en fait si on a pris le choix et ce
virus est bien qui est imprévisible
aussi parlé de revers tueur diverses et
miné
s'il est retenu nous souhaitons et il a
prôné heureux nous nous paraît prématuré
monsieur le premier ministre nous sommes
un an après la mise en place de
politiques diverses pour tester tracé
isolés que nous allons voter ou non
d'ailleurs dans cet hémicycle
autant d'éléments pour lesquelles nous
disposions disposant pas d'évaluation et
nous permet de douter de leur efficacité
nous sommes maintenant à près toujours
autant d'incertitudes pour des millions
de français qui est sympa si pour un
jour se soigner travailler étudier halle
au cinéma au restaurant ou au café
bref reprendre une vie normale et
descentes au final ces cas manquer
c'est un débat préalable au parlement
car c'est bien le freeroll de voter la
loi et de contrôler votre action
conformément à l'article 24 de notre
constitution
ce qui a manqué aussi c'est là qu'on
tient dans les locaux qui souvent sont
les plus à même de prendre des décisions
pour le territoire mettant non la place
du maire de cordes tard où nous sommes
si voix la décision arrive hélas au
civisme renesmée la fermeture de
commerces sont essentiels sans avoir été
consultés ce qui manque aux phoques
c'est là qu'on vienne le concitoyen des
élus de ces territoires
la majorité des membres du rdr ce dont
vous connaissez il attachement à nos
institutions et à volonté de placer
l'intérêt du pays au delà de toute
querelle partisane liberté les mises
ainsi qu'une image relation rassemblés
face aux défis auxquels nous sommes
confrontés et là je me suis le premier
ministre l'unité nationale ne se décrète
pas elle se construit aussi vous
comprenez que notre groupe paramore pas
à l'unanimité mais dans sa très grande
majorité ne prendra pas part au vote
merci monsieur leader
je vais vous en donner la parole madame
la présidente eliane assassi pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
écologisme madame la présidente vous
avez la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
si la vie de milliers de nos
compatriotes ne tenez pas aujourd'hui à
un fil si la vie sociale et économique
du pays n'étaient pas bouleversé le
débat auquel vous nous convoquer
aujourd'hui s'apparenterait à une
mauvaise blague une nouvelle fois le
président de la république a présenté
seul hier des mesures pour lutter contre
la pandémie décider seul accompagné par
le seul conseil de défense
le parlement est donc définitivement
perçue comme une chambre
d'enregistrement écarté progressivement
depuis le début de la crise est
aujourd'hui définitivement mis sur la
touche
nous sommes donc convoqué aujourd'hui
pour vous écoutez nous expliquer les
décisions présidentielles au cas où nous
n'aurions pas bien compris et de
surcroît vous demander de voter sur des
propositions qui d'une part n'ont
absolument pas été débattue
préalablement et d'autre part dont nous
ignorons les motivations en clair nous
ne savons pas pourquoi
emmanuel macron a décidé certaine mesure
qu'ils rejetaient quelques jours plus
tôt et pourquoi il en a écarté d'autres
dès le début de la crise ici même le 19
mars 2020 nous avons alerté sur le
risque de dérive autoritaire que
comportait l'état d'urgence sanitaire
depuis des mois nous demandons de
renoncer à s'était pas d'exception qui
met le couvercle sur la démocratie
rappelez vous mes chers collègues de la
dernière prorogation
nous avons rappelé que l'état d'urgence
n'était plus une justification mais que
la gravité exigeait de rendre au
parlement
sa capacité permanente de décision la
représentation nationale
c'est la représentation du peuple mais
le premier ministre
le parlement c'est cela et non un
aéropage de gens inutiles comme au temps
du conseil des cinq sens monsieur
macouin il vous même renvoyé à l'opinion
publique cette constitution qui serait
la vôtre du parlement le mépris du
parlement est patent et nous tenons à
exprimer solennellement notre désaccord
profond avec cette pratique
institutionnelle c'est même si le
premier mis de la colère car nous
constatons la mise en pratique de la
volonté jupitérienne d'écarter le
parlement de sa route alors que la
révision constitutionnelle préparé par
le chef de l'état n'a pu être imposée
ici ni au pays
cette dérive autocratique beaucoup ont
souligné dénoncé dès les premières
heures du quinquennat prend une
dimension inquiétante aujourd'hui le
président de la république écartant tout
de son chemin parlement conseil des
ministres puisque le conseil de défense
détournée de son objet initial fixé par
l'article 15 de la constitution relatif
au rôle de chef des armées du président
le supplée mêmes le conseil scientifique
puisque emmanuel macron si l'on en croit
les éloges de monsieur bancaire détient
la connaissance voire la science infuse
en matière épidémiologique l'exercice
solitaire du pouvoir n'est jamais une
bonne chose pour la démocratie et en
temps de crise cela peut générer des
drames
la reprise en main par le parlement par
le collectif par la démocratie devient
une nécessité absolue
monsieur macway nous a donc présenté
hier soir ses choix nouveau changement
de pied avec la fermeture bref pour
l'instant des établissements scolaires
et abandon de la stratégie territoriale
on aura d'ailleurs noté cette étonnante
initiative au nom de la respiration
d'autoriser la circulation dans tout le
pays jusqu'au 5 avril pour permettre
sans doute aux propriétaires de
résidences secondaires en particulier de
passer trois semaines où le mois à venir
au vert ces évolutions manifeste pour
l'école ou dans les jours qui
précédaient les ministres monsieur
gérant est monsieur blanc caire expliqué
que la situation était maîtrisée
un lion au nom de la nouvelle donne du
variant anglais monsieur le premier
ministre nous savions vous saviez le 29
janvier lorsque a été prise la décision
de ne pas re consignes et et de préférer
des mesures de freinage qui ont échoué
vous saviez donc que le vario anglais
pouvaient avoir des effets dévastateurs
dans notre pays
le 19 janvier l'inserm 19 janvier
l'inserm a mis en ligne une modélisation
estimant que le variant anglais je cite
deviendrait dominant entre fin février
et mi mars
l'inserm avait également annoncé le
niveau d'hospitalisation qui va
intervenir dans les jours à venir
nous avons noté le scepticisme au sein
même du gouvernement concernant les
annonces de boris johnson le 22 janvier
sur un vert un invariant potentiellement
plus mortelle le 10 mars une étude
incontesté affirmé je cite que ce
variant anglais étaient 64 % plus
mortelle monsieur macron savez vous
saviez
et pourtant vous avez attendu d'être dos
au mur celui de la saturation des
services de réanimation pour agir et
l'avenir nous dira si ces décisions sont
suffisantes
nous ne détenons pas la vérité monsieur
le premier ministre
pas plus que vous sur cette épidémie les
rebondissements dramatiques invite me
semble-t-il à l'humilité mais il y à une
vérité que monsieur macro à dissimuler
hier en demandant même plus d'efforts
aux soignants c'est cette saturation et
les prix déjà engagée puisque ne jouons
pas sur les mots des programmes et des
opérations c'est bien trier des malades
les mettre en danger
et vous savez très bien qu'aujourd'hui
la question va se poser très vite des du
tri des malades de la commission
maquereau a annoncé par un retour de la
pause c'est magique que dix lits de
réanimation allait être ouvert
rapidement sans plus de précision de
délai monsieur prémunissent je vous ai
interrogé ici même il ya quinze jours
sur la promesse non tenue depuis un an
d'ouverture d'ouverture de ces lits de
réanimation
pour vous les lignes peuvent se
commander chez ikea ou être créés sur un
claquement de doigts de doigts vous ne
pouviez pas monsieur macro l'a fait
qu'en pensez vous le président cherche
t-il à faire oublier qu'avec vous il
poursuit contrairement à ses dires
depuis un an la fermeture des lui ce qui
a été annoncé hier
c'est l'absence totale d'anticipation
comme l'a noté la cour des comptes en
matière de réanimation
excusez moi monsieur le premier ministre
mais votre gouvernement est resté les
deux pieds dans le même sabot en la
matière engoncée dans le dogme libéral
d'économie de la dépense publique et les
conséquences sont aujourd'hui dramatique
le quoi qu'il en coûte n'a pas été
appliquée pour l'hôpital monsieur le
premier ministre l'espoir c'est le
vaccin mais là aussi vous avez failli
mais pas seulement vous le système tout
entier
cette fameuse wadi marché que dénoncer
emmanuel macron dans son discours du 9
mars 2020
le retard mortifère pris en matière de
vaccination puisque ce nous puis son
origine dans le fléau de la concurrence
du profit des gains sur la maladie les
petits mensonges travestissement de la
vérité les vaccinodromes que l'homo que
lombok puisque le convoque en urgence
les élus municipaux que l'on critique
longue rides mais qui sauve la situation
tout cela n'aurait pas eu lieu si le
vaccin avait été promu comme un bien
commun
sorti des logiques capitalistes pour
servir l'intérêt général sans autre
profite de la protection de l'humanité
pourquoi la france
nagy t'elle pas pour la levée des
brevets pouvez-vous nous répondre
monsieur le premier ministre
quelle est la boussole du président la
santé de nos compatriotes tous le
sauvetage d'une économie mondialisée en
crise profonde la question mérite d'être
posée
l'école enfin l'école oui maintenir les
écoles ouvertes est un souhait largement
partagée nous le partageons
mais à quel prix donnez-nous les
éléments pour savoir combien de vies ont
été perdues et chacun ici à un proche un
ami malade ou décédées du fait du retard
pris pour limiter l'expansion du variant
angles et les jours les semaines à venir
apporteront cette réponse monsieur le
premier ministre des balles je les dis
d'entraîneur
pect pas le parlement nous devrions
débattre des mesures à prendre
elles sont déjà prises c'est la
confiance que vous devriez aujourd'hui
demander au parlement et croyez moi nous
ne vous l'aurions pas accordé dans la
gestion de cette épidémie est contraire
aux intérêts de notre pays de notre
peuple mais aujourd'hui avec la quasi
totalité des groupes politiques du
parlement
nous avons décidé en toute
responsabilité de ne pas participer au
vote sur votre déclaration
car cette consultation des pas
respectueuse de la constitution équipe
usée elle est marquée monsieur le
premier ministre d'une certaine
hypocrisie
merci madame la présidente
[Applaudissements]
pour répondre aux orateurs je vais
d'abord donné la parole au ministre des
solidarités de la santé monsieur virant
puis à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le ministre de la solidarité et
de la santé monsieur le président du
sénat madame et messieurs les sénateurs
d'abord vous tenez vous remercier pour
la qualité des débats et des échanges
pense avoir perçu à travers vos
différentes interventions que peu de
groupes se prononceront c'est votre
choix de voter c'est votre choix de ne
pas voter par définition ça reste
constitutionnel comme l'est d'ailleurs
madame la sénatrice vin représente assez
ans il le fait de provoquer un débat
avec vote comme celui qui nous
réunissent sans quoi si ce n'était pas
constitutionnelle nous ne serions pas là
le sourire gouesnou ailleurs occupé à
d'autres affaires sur le sur le fond des
questions est ce qu on a quand même eu
quelques unes unes des questions d'abord
sur la priorisation de la vaccination et
notamment sur la priorisation de la
vaccination en dc à destination des
enseignants je crois que c'est
essentiellement le présent marseille qui
nous a interpellés avec des questions
sur le fond il est prévu vous savez
d'abord de prioriser les publics les
plus fragiles par tranche d'âge ce que
nous avons fait depuis le début
92 % des résidents en ehpad sont
protégés la vaccination ensuite
progressé chez les plus de 75 ans les
plus de 70 ans bientôt les plus de 60
ans et à un moment donné on aura
protéger suffisamment les publics les
plus vulnérables celles et ceux qui vont
en réanimation qui décèdent des formes
graves du code vide ce qui on a vacciné
dont on voit aujourd'hui qu'il entraîne
on a nous permet d'avoir une baisse de
la mortalité par rapport à l'intensité
de l'épidémie et c'est heureux et
ensuite nous allons pouvoir actionner
des publics prioritaires alors vous
poser une question très légitime qu'est
ce qui est un public prioritaire et qui
ne l'est pas présents la république a
souhaité que les enseignants eu égard au
fait que les classes sont restées
ouvertes
vous le savez beaucoup plus longtemps
que dans les pays qui nous entourent
puissent être vaccinés
rapidement il a également évoqué les
forces de l'ordre qui peuvent être
amenés à faire des interventions y
compris physique auprès de personnes qui
sont potentiellement contagieuse sans
pouvoir forcément garantir des distances
et jean michel blanquer qui ne manquent
pas depuis des semaines de se mobiliser
à raison pour pouvoir vacciner
les enseignants à proposer également une
idée que je trouve très bonne qui est de
commencer par d'actionner les
enseignants qui sont au contact des
enfants en situation de handicap
je crois qu'ici tout le monde pourra
reconnaître que c'est une proposition
aussi juste que pragmatique et je
souhaite que nous puissions
effectivement accordé à cordes et cela
très rapidement
deuxième type de questions qui ont été
posées c'était sur les autotests alors
d'abord quand vous comparez la france et
l'allemagne sur les tests c'est votre
droit comparé l'a complètement s'il vous
plaît parce que si la france le 3
millions de tests par semaine un tiers
de ces tests c'est à dire un million de
tests par semaine sont de tests
antigénique donc savaient qu'ils sont
réalisés à la fois un laboratoire en
pharmacie en médecine de ville par les
infirmiers tous les soignants qui sont
gratuits sans ordonnance et si vous
regardez du côté côté outre-rhin
c'est la possibilité les tests
antigénique en population générale ont
été introduits à peu près à mois à
raison d'une livraison de 40 mille tests
rembourser le reste faisant appel à du
reste à charge pour les populations de
sorte qu'en réalité l'allemagne
disposera désormais de tests pcr et
d'autotest là où nous disposons de tests
pcr de tests antigénique depuis des mois
et des mois et vous le savez et nous
allons introduire et c'est une bonne
nouvelle
des autotests et non pas les autotests
parce qu'il ya des autotests qui sont de
bonne qualité qui n'ont pas encore de
marca chez eux mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs mais que nous allons autoriser
en fast track pour qu'ils puissent être
rendus disponibles pour les français le
plus vite possible et des autres
hôtesses de mauvaise qualité dont l'
incident dont la sensibilité est telle
que si vous jetez une pièce en l'air
vous avez plus de chance de tomber sur
un bon résultat cela si nous les
mettions à disposition des français
je pense mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs que vous ne manqueriez pas de
vous en faire reproche d'ici à quelques
semaines
considérant que nous aurions joué que la
santé des français en fait le leitmotiv
depuis le début c'est qu'il faut aller
vite et vous avez raison il faut aller
fort il faut refuser tous les blocages
tous les obstacles quand ils sont
inutiles mais il ne faut pas faire
n'importe quoi et par endroits mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs il ya eu les
propositions qui sont les mêmes qui ont
émané du sénat qui était de bonne
proposition
et parfois il ya eu des propositions qui
savent pas renter à des formes de seine
pression et qu'ils ne se sont pas
avérées gagnante monsieur président
retailleau je ne vous ferai pas l'injure
de vous rappeler les débats que nous
avons eus sur des médicaments dont on
sait aujourd'hui qu'il ne fonctionne pas
et dont j'étais rendu coupable de ne pas
vouloir le précieux comme des bonbons à
tous les français je citerai les paroles
du président ça m'arrive pas souvent
ball sonar au brésil qui après l'avoir
distribué en sachet plastique adedy
de milliers de personnes a dit bon ok ça
marche pas mais au moins ça sans doute
tué personne je n'ai pas à rougir
monsieur le député d'avoir tenu tête par
endroits à des discours futile monsieur
le sénateur pardon même si ces discours
était parfois assez virulent et par par
moment pas dans votre bouche bien sûr
mais dans la bouche d'autres collègues
pouvaient confiné à la démagogie sur les
lits de réanimation c'est pareil
et vous avez au fond très bien compris
monsieur retailleau parce que nous en
avons parlé ensemble et nous en avons
parlé ensemble il ya plusieurs mois de
cela
vous savez monsieur retailleau comment
fonctionne la montée de lits de
réanimation
vous savez que l'on mobilisé et qui vous
l'avez dit vous-même qu'on transfère
d'une unité de soins pour aller leur
permettre de soigner des gens dans des
unités de réanimation éphémères ou
durables
il ya des unités durable et qui ont été
créés à paris par exemple l'hôpital
henri mondor plus de 150 lits je crois
ont été créées l'année dernière nous
allons recréer 60 et c'est à nous
montons ses capacités et puis et des
transformations de bloc opératoire les
transformations de salle de réveil ça ça
mobilise non seulement du personnel
c'est vrai et nous recrutons les
étudiants les retraités la réserve
sanitaire les libéraux les salariés nous
faisons nous bouger tout le monde et il
traverse le pays quand il le faut pour
venir aider les collègues mais ça permet
ça nécessite aussi de la déprogrammation
et nous pouvons monter à dix mille nous
sommes montés à 10400 lit il y à un
homme nous pouvons le faire nous pouvons
le faire mais au prix d'une
déprogrammation intense la différence
entre il ya un an
et cette année c'est qu'il ya un an moi
j'avais demandé un plan blanc dans tous
les hôpitaux en exigeant la
déprogrammation de tous les actes dans
toute la france pour que nous soyons
prêts parce que nous ne savions pas à
quel vitesse montrer la vague
aujourd'hui nous savons à quelle vitesse
sont la vague nous prenons entre 50 et
100 patients de plus en réanimation par
jour ça veut dire que chaque jour nous
déployons 50 à 100 lits de réanimation
en plus et si je demandais aux
établissements publics et privés de
déprogrammer tous les soins pour monter
d'un seul coup à dix mille lits et qu'on
est donc 3000 lits de réanimation qui
attendrait des patients qui ne seraient
pas encore là vous ne manqueriez pas de
me dire ou es ce que vous avez pas perdu
la boule
tous ces patients vous n'avez pas opéré
pendant des semaines vous auriez très
bien pu les opérer et procéder au
dernier moment à la montée des leaders
et a fait confiance aux soignants fait
confiance à nos soignants c'est eux qui
sont en permanence au contact des
malades
c
qui savent quand ça devient chaud et
qu'ils ont besoin d'ouvrir des nouveaux
lits ou des nouvelles unités
c'est eux qui sont accompagnés au
quotidien jour et nuit dans les
programmes de des programmes dans les
plans de déprogrammation pour monter nos
capacités d'accueil
il ya une question qui était posée sur
le pass sanitaire vous dire que on est
dans un pays qui a une passion de
l'égalité
je pense qu'on a raison ma conviction
personnelle en la matière mais il faut
qu'il y ait un débat et ce débat doit
être démocratique doit traverser les
chambres parlementaires et c'est tout à
fait normal c'est que je considère que
le jour on pourra rouvrir des lieux pour
le public qui doivent être rouverts pour
tous je ne considère pas à titre
personnel qu'on puisse dire un français
que s'il est vacciné il peut aller
manger au restaurant qui ne l'est pas
une pas vaccinés ne puisse pas y aller
nous verrons peut-être que j'aurai tort
voyez c'est pas un paris 7e c'est une
opinion que je vous livre mais qui n'a
pas de conséquences alors laquelle je
vous parle les travaux sont conduits
préparatoires sur le plan juridique
sanitaire scientifique légistique qui
nous permettront d'avoir toute façon ce
débat crucial pour l'avenir de notre
pays
enfin vous avez posé la question de
savoir si c'était trop tard enfin vous
avez pas posé la question vous avez
déterminé que c'était trop tard pour
confiner et que si on avait confirmé
plus tôt c'aurait été mieux
moi je vous dis exactement ce qu'on se
serait dit si le pays avait été confiné
le 29 janvier aujourd'hui on serait en
train de se parler du confinement
parce que confiné le 29 janvier n'aurait
pas empêché le variant de monter il n'a
empêché le variant de monter ni en
allemagne ni en italie ni dans les pays
les autres pays qui ont confiné pendant
des semaines et des mois
aujourd'hui ce que nous pouvons
constater c'est que oui nous avons gagné
du temps du temps de liberté
certes sous contrainte avec un couvre
feu mais du temps de liberté quand même
les commerces et les écoles sont restés
ouverts en france beaucoup plus
longtemps qu'à l'étranger
les pauses et monsieur retailleau
présent retailleau la question du risque
juridique et vous avez posé la question
de savoir si le risque juridique qui
pouvait peser sur nos épaules était à
même de nous freiner dans des dents des
décisions mais pour vous répondre je me
permettrai une métaphore et l'appel à un
film que j'aime beaucoup parce que c'est
un film qui m'effraie en même temps que
je le trouve esthétique
c'est un vieux film s'appelle bienvenue
à gattaca vous avez deux frères qui
traverse qui font une course de nage
dans la mer de nuit y en a qui handicape
et l'autre est très en forme et c'est
celui qui est en situation de handicap
qui va le plus loin
enfin le regarde et lui dit mais comment
fais tu pour aller aussi loin et son
petit frère lui répond je n'ai jamais
économisé mes forces pour le retour
quand on gère une crise sanitaire comme
ça comme nous le faisons depuis 13 mois
monsieur le sénateur nous n'est qu'au
nomi sont pas nos forces et notre
énergie
nous allons là où nous pensons qu'il est
bon que nous allions parce que c'est
l'enjeu de protéger les français
je vous remercie merci la parole est
maintenant à monsieur le premier
ministre jean castex
quand vous voulez mais ce que le premier
c'est le président mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs
nous arrivons au terme de ce débat je
voudrais vous dire d'emblée par rapport
à ce que j'ai entendu c'est que si avec
beaucoup de ministres de mon
gouvernement je suis ici devant vous cet
après midi c'est précisément parce que
je respecte beaucoup le parlement et le
sénat
nous en administre ont d'ailleurs tout
au long des sessions la preuve ne pas
respecter le parlement et le sénat
ce serait le privé des droits et des
prérogatives qu'il tient de notre
constitution des institutions de la vème
république libre à certains il ne s'en
prive pas de critiquer cette
constitution de critiquer ses
institutions
c'est l'endroit mais on ne peut quand
même pas reprocher au gouvernement la
république d'appliquer la constitution
d'un république tout ce qui en
application de l'article 34 de la
constitution dans la gestion de cette
crise sanitaire relève du parlement est
soumis au parlement
et aujourd'hui comme je les dis ce matin
à l'assemblée nationale je suis venu
vous présenter et vous demander
effectivement de vous prononcer parce
que la démocratie c'est la clarté c'est
la responsabilité de vous prononcer sur
des prérogatives du pouvoir exécutif
je ne suis pas certain de vous avoir
le général de gaulle pour lequel je voue
un immense respect n'aurait pas trouvé
iconoclaste qu'un gouvernement vain
demandé au parlement l'approbation de
dispositions relevant de son autorité
c'est pourtant ce que nous faisons de la
même façon je le dis la gestion de cette
crise mesdames et messieurs des
sénateurs est extrêmement transparents
jamais jamais les données c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'opendata jamais toutes les
données sanitaires économiques
épidémiologique n'ont été autant mise en
ligne
bien entendu à la disposition cela va
sans dire de la représentation nationale
mais de l'ensemble de nos concitoyens et
vous avez sans doute observé avec moi
qu'il ne se prive pas de s'en saisir
pour commenter critiquer c'est leurs
droits élémentaires en démocratie
l'action des pouvoirs publics et du
gouvernement
à chaque fois que le parlement nous
posent des questions nous répondons à
chaque fois que le parlement dans le
cadre des pouvoirs légitimes de contrôle
qui sont les siens à chaque fois donc
qu'il nous interroge
nous répondons et tel est d'ailleurs
l'instruction que je donne
quotidiennement au ministre c'est le
sens oui il ya cette procédure c'est pas
moi qui l'inventé
c'est pas vous en fait je sais qu'il a
inventé et nous l'appliquons parce que
justement dans le cadre d'une gestion de
crise qui suppose toujours des
prérogatives spécifiques pour le pouvoir
exécutif
en france comme ailleurs en france comme
ailleurs
mais le moment est grave ce n'est pas la
première fois que je le fais vous la
fait rappeler je les fais au moment du
deuxième confinement je les fais pour
venir vous présenter la stratégie
vaccinale fait je n'ai pas pu venir moi
même j'étais qu'un contact mais j'étais
évidemment représenté
je le fais aujourd'hui à des moments
graves justement où en considération de
la représentation nationale
je viens expliqué les tenants les
motivations et le contenu des mesures
difficiles que le gouvernement s'apprête
à prendre
en vertu des pouvoirs que la
constitution démocratique de notre pays
lui a attribués rien de plus mais rien
de moins et je vous le dis sans le
commenter
c'est votre choix prendre par ce vote
dans le sens qu en votre âme et
conscience
vous auriez souhaité lui donner aurait
été un exercice de clarification et de
responsabilité qui ne vous aurait pas je
n'en espérais pas moins rendu qu'on
responsable de l'action des pouvoirs
publics
cette action je veux vous le dire elle
est très difficile vous le savez
d'ailleurs je note
je note sur le fond cette fois ci on
s'est placé derrière les grands
principes mais sur le fond je note
finalement beaucoup d'interventions
mesuré de votre pas mesdames et
messieurs sénateurs reconnaissant que la
situation n'est pas simple
admettant nous avons maintenant beaucoup
de recul les uns et les autres que ce
qui se passe à l'étranger viennent aussi
peut-être tempérer les commentaires
catégorique ou expéditif nous avons
effectivement je voulais expliquer une
épidémie qui s'accélère une épidémie qui
est plus dangereuse
une épidémie
qui va ici comme ailleurs plus vite que
la vaccination et qui nous obligent à
prendre des mesures complémentaires sur
lesquels je suis venu ici vous rendre
des comptes
mais soyons clairs je le dis à tous les
intervenants peut-être président en
colère qui me dit j'ai bien noté je vous
écoute toujours comme à vous tous le
résultat de tout cela c'est à dire de
l'action du président de la république
et de son gouvernement c'est un nouveau
confinement vous avez vous dit de façon
désolé cher président mais dans le même
temps finalement nous reprochant de
l'avoir fait plus tôt mais comprenne qui
pourra
comprenne qui pourra parce que je le dis
danger interroge les uns les autres
j'entends souvent monsieur le président
il faut prendre des mesures plus
difficile vous l'avez eu 10 géré présent
oui mais après comme l'a dit sur tes
yeux tout est dans l'art d'exécution et
on la connaît mais c'est quoi un
confinement fermé des commerces à
monsieur le premier surtout pas fermer
les écoles c'est le dernier rempart vous
seriez même peut-être respirer de
rouvrir des établissements publics
culturels des universités des pistes de
ski
j'ai même entendu des discothèques vous
voyez toutes et tous ici ce à quoi je
fais allusion je vous respecte trop pour
l'ignorer bref bref
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
notre objectif en tout cas celui du
gouvernement c'est toujours de prendre
les mesures proportionnées d'abord sur
des critères sanitaires je vous le
répète d'abord sur des critères
sanitaires mais pas que c'est notre rôle
de politique pas que sur des critères
sanitaires pas que sur des critères et
vous le savez bien et l'exemple donné
par le président malhuret
parmi d'autres est extrêmement
illustratif
certains médecins vous explique qu'il
faut fermer les écoles quand leurs
collègues pédiatre non moins médecin me
semble-t-il nous recommande linverse
donc rien qui ne nous permettent d'être
catégorique tout qui nous invite à être
mesurée à être progressif à être
proportionnée et face à la gravité de la
situation nous devons donc prendre des
mesures plus grave c'est ce que nous
faisons nous en mesurons croyez le bien
vous les avez souligné les impacts
considérables pour nos concitoyens et en
particulier je le dis surtout les
groupes parce qu'un consensus ya un
consensus fermer des écoles c'est la
dernière extrémité
seul mini l'homme sait bien que si on le
fait nous qui avons été quasiment dans
le monde entier
parmi les derniers à recourir à cette
extrémité c'est que malheureusement la
situation n'exige et pardonnez moi le
faire maintenant alors qu'il ya des
vacances c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose pour les incidents scolaire que de
le faire il ya quinze jours ça n'est pas
vrai bien donc c'est quand même calculé
il va falloir nous serrer les coudes
je dis pas forcément titre politique
bien sûr je ne suis pas naïf je dis pour
notre pays pour faire face à cette
nouvelle épreuve je vous trouve je vous
le dis tout et tous tel que je le pense
particulièrement sévère c'est votre
droit mais accepter le mien de vous
faire part de ma pensée sur les sujets
de la vaccination mais non ne faisons
pas croire à nos compatriotes qu'on
pourrait trouver des doses d'un porte ou
sur président retailleau l'allemagne
avez-vous dit d'ambassadeur je connais
bien le sujet venu vous dire on peut
commander des doses unilatéralement
l'at-il fait l'allemagne at-elle fait
vous savez bien que non pourquoi parce
que parallèlement parce que
parallèlement l'europe l'europe c'était
je crois des doses pas isère je parle
sur le contrôle des ministres compétents
en a commandé beaucoup plus
cet exemple est très illustratif ne dit
pas non c'est la vérité c'est la vérité
et vous savez bien que si chaque état
si chaque état comme quelques rares
l'ont fait
comment des to
de leur côté le résultat on le connaît
il ferait pas produire une seule dose de
plus les prix montrer mais bien sûr mais
bien sûr on les sert à croire les sert à
croire c'est votre responsabilité à nos
concitoyens qu'on pourrait oui les faits
sont là qu'on pourrait trouver plus de
doses plus de doses qu'il y en a ce
n'est pas raisonnable
ce n'est pas responsable notre devoir en
revanche c'est de vacciner autant que
possible dès que toutes les doses sol a
le devoir de l'europe c'est de faire
respecter les contrats qu on souscrit
les industriels et les laboratoires
ça oui et croyez bien que nous nous y
employons avec la dernière énergie
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
notre système de santé est très éprouvé
je leur dis à ceux qui se sont exprimés
là non plus ne faisons pas croire qu'on
peut créer des lits de réanimation en un
an
ça n'est pas possible en vous là mais
vous ne faites pas semblant de ne pas
avoir compris on reconvertit des forces
au service de la réanimation mais on ne
fait pas madame à ça si on ne on ne
forme pas d'un et saisissent très
novateur en un an n'ont plus qu'une
amnistie zié une infirmière anesthésiste
et vous le savez et monsieur je les dis
monsieur kader tout ça vient de loin
tout ça vient de loin je le dis au
président caennais requis nous dit vous
fermez encore des lits je suis obligé de
rappeler devant le sénat ce que j'ai dit
ce matin l'assemblée nationale les
moyens l'hôpital c'est un nom ça
s'appelle l'omdar hospitalier je
voudrais vous redonnez monsieur kader
les chiffres de l'andam hospitalier
exécuté en 2012 2,6 pour cent en 2013
2,1 pour cent en 2014 1,7 pour cent en
2000 x16 1,5 pour ça voilà à la fin
d'année 2009 plus 8,9 pour cent mais
dans le plfss 2021 +10
2 pour ça voilà alors soyons tous
raisonnable et humble les difficultés
les difficultés de notre hôpital ne date
pas d'aujourd'hui nous le savons toutes
et tous nous ne nous le savons toutes et
tous nous le savons toutes et tous
condamnent étaient encore supérieures à
ce moment là chers sénateurs milan je
peux vous donner tous les chiffres mais
ne laissons pas à croire que ces
difficultés viennent aujourd'hui et que
surtout s'agissant de postes aussi
technique que les anesthésistes
réanimateurs on va pouvoir en recruter
est en forme et dans des durée aussi
courte
ce n'est pas vrai en revanche comme vous
l'a très bien expliqué répété le
ministre
nous faisons tout pour les renforcer
pour reconvertir pour redéployer pour
faire appel à des réserves pour qu'ils
puissent faire face comme ils le font si
admirablement depuis maintenant quatorze
mois je vous remercie
merci monsieur le premier ministre mes
chers collègues à la demande du
gouvernement le sénat est appelé à se
prononcer par un vote cette déclaration
conformément à l'article 9 alinéa 6 de
notre règlement il va donc les procédés
un scrutin public ordinaire dans les
conditions prévues par l'article 56 du
règlement se rappelle qu' il n'y a pas
d'explications de vote et je vais
maintenant ouvrir le scrutin le scrutin
est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos
les résultats du scrutin numéros sont
compte tenu de l'ensemble des
délégations de vote accordés par les
électeurs aux groupes politiques et
notifiée à la présidence le nombre de
votants s'est élevé à 45 le nombre de
suffrages exprimés à 41 pour l'adoption
39 contre 2 le sénat a adopté voilà
je vais maintenant suspende la séance
elle sera reprise à 17h40 pour la
nouvelle lecture de la proposition de
loi visant à améliorer le système de
santé
c'est tout un programme par la confiance
et la simplification
la séance est suspendue
la séance s'est reprise madame la
ministre madame la présidente monsieur
le rapporteur mes chers collègues
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion en
nouvelle lecture de la proposition de
loi adoptée avec modification par
l'assemblée nationale en nouvelle
lecture visant à améliorer le système de
santé par la confiance et la
simplification dans la discussion
générale
la parole est à madame brigitte
bourguignon ministre délégué auprès du
ministre solidarité et de la santé merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales nous sommes réunis
aujourd'hui en nouvelle lecture d'un
texte majeur pour concrétiser les
engagements du ségur de la santé dans un
contexte sanitaire particulier nous
devons à nos soignants particulièrement
mobilisés dans les établissements de
santé
aujourd'hui encore davantage pour
accroître nos capacités de prise en
charge leur accorder la confiance et les
marges de manoeuvre sur lesquels nous
étions engagés dans le cadre du secteur
de la santé le secteur de la santé ce
sont des sommes sans précédent mise sur
la table des revalorisations ambitieuse
depuis septembre et des investissements
pour l'ensemble du système de santé
sanitaire médico-social et numérique
dont nous avons lancé un premier projet
avec le premier ministre
9 mars dernier ces revalorisations été
signé le 13 juillet dernier à matignon
et elle profite à l'ensemble des
personnels médicaux paramédicaux de
l'hôpital et des ehpad publics
elles ont été étendues aux personnels
des établissements et services sociaux
et médico sociaux rattachés aux hôpitaux
publics par un accord le 16 février
dernier et des négociations continuent
de se poursuivre pour rendre ces métiers
du public plus attractif il n'y aura pas
d'oublier du ségur
au-delà de ces revalorisations
salariales attendue depuis longtemps par
delà les âges et les alternances le
ségur de la santé a permis de partage
un techno stick d'ampleur qu'il s'agisse
d'investissements pour regarder l'avenir
avec confiance
qu'il s'agisse de gouvernance pour
assurer une juste participation de ceux
qui soignent qu'il s'agisse de
l'élargissement des compétences des
professionnels de santé
nous n'avons éludé aucun sujet certaines
des avancées apportées par la haute
assemblée ont été conservés par
l'assemblée nationale
mais lors des travaux parlementaires
nous avons tenu un équilibre avec les
travaux de l'ordonance de l'article 37
de la loi organisation transformation du
système de santé relative aux j'ai
acheté qui a été présenté en conseil des
ministres le 17 mars dernier et les
commissions médicales de groupements
seront demain des instances
décisionnelles dans la vie de ces
établissements par conséquence les
missions des commissions médicales
d'établissement de groupement et leur
président sont ainsi revues suite aux
recommandations du rapport clarisse qui
ont fixé le cap que nous suivons
par ailleurs le segura préconisé la
réhabilitation du rôle et de la place du
service au sein de l'hôpital
en reprenant notamment une préconisation
du rapport du professeur caris cette
proposition de loi répond également vous
le savez à la revendication ancienne de
donner aux acteurs locaux une plus
grande liberté d'organisation interne
s'agissant par exemple des
établissements de santé la crise a
montré et nous démontre encore que les
collectifs de soins savait s'adapter
s'organiser surmonter des décisions
extrêmement et des situations
extrêmement sensible sans attendre pour
cela un accord
une validation un feu vert venu d'en
haut si dans un hôpital
les communautés sont d'accord pour
adapter l'organisation médicale pour
avoir une gouvernance un peu différentes
de l'établissement d'à côté qu'est ce
qui justifierait de l'en empêcher
c'est un sujet de confiance et nous nous
avons une confiance forte en les acteurs
de terrain nous devons continuer à
progresser en matière de démocratie
hospitalière ce texte propose justement
de fiers de faire siéger au directoire
des établissements publics hospitaliers
un représentant des personnels non
médicaux un représentant des étudiants
en santé et un représentant des usagers
dont nous avons à apprendre c'est une
liberté donnée aux acteurs et nous y
tenons
et c'est encore un gage de confiance par
ailleurs le gouvernement s'est engagé
fortement dans la lutte contre le
mercenariat de l'intérim médical qui
désorganise l'offre de soins dans nos
territoires et met à mal les finances de
nos hôpitaux
vous aviez eu un débat intéressant en
première lecture qui a démontré les
limites
les dispositions actuelles et la
nécessité d'aller plus loin dans le
contrôle de l'intérim pour mettre fin
aux dérives
le texte ainsi rédigé permet une bonne
fois pour toutes de rendre effectif le
plafond réglementaire de l'intérim
médicale en obligeant le comptable
public à rejeter tout paiement au delà
de ce plafond
cette proposition de loi renforce
également un certain nombre de
mouvements nés cet été avec le ségur de
la santé l'un de ces mouvements c'est
l'extension du champ de compétences de
certaines professions et je pense en
particulier aux sages femmes aux
masseurs kinésithérapeutes aux
orthophonistes et aux ergothérapeute
ouvrir le champ des actes ouverts à ces
professions c'est faire le choix de la
confiance et de l'efficacité
nous faisons le pari que notre système
de santé ne sera en mesure de relever
les défis auxquels il fait face comme on
part avec les querelles de chapelle et
les prés carrés dans lesquelles certains
souhaiteraient nous enfermer de la même
manière nous avons élargi l'étendue du
rapport sur les protocoles de
coopération et pratiques avancées à la
question spécifique de l'accès à des
pratiques avancées aux infirmiers
spécialisés notamment aux infirmiers
anesthésistes afin de reconnaître leurs
compétences
j'ai tenu à revenir sur les principaux
axes de cette proposition de loi
car ils constituent autant d'évolutions
attendu par les acteurs et pour notre
système de santé
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs suis
très heureuse de voir le ségur de la
santé revenir aujourd'hui dans cet
hémicycle
j'ai hâte que nos débats deviennent des
ré
lité concrètes sur le terrain je tiens à
saluer le travail de toutes celles et
tous ceux qui ont enrichi ce texte et de
toutes celles et tous ceux qui
contribueront à lui donner la force
d'une promesse tenue
je vous remercie merci madame la
ministre la parole est maintenant
monsieur alain milon ah bon et bien donc
la parole n'est pas alain milon la
parole est donnée à madame catherine de
roche présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales merci madame les
voyageurs du fait de bouleversement du
de l'agenda de cet après-midi le
rapporteur alain milon et tenues de
partir donc je vais vous lire ce qu'il
avait prévu de dire en science publique
donc monsieur le président madame le
ministre mes chers collègues nous
engageons l'examen en nouvelle lecture
d'une proposition de loi sans ligne
directrice forte dont nous avions
regretté largement sur ces bancs le
manque d'ambition et le caractère
décousu
alors que notre système de santé sous
une pression inédite ce texte
à ce moment nous discutions laisse un
goût d'inachevé
sans vraiment tirer les enseignements de
cette crise ils peinent à répondre aux
vives attentes exprimées dans le c ur de
la santé faire confiance et simplifiée
comme aux promesses de selon titulaire
en raison d'un trop grand nombre de
divergences entre la proche du sénat et
celle de l'assemblée nationale à
l'origine de cette initiative
la commission mixte paritaire réunie le
2 mars n'est pas parvenue à établir un
texte commun la poursuite de la navette
a confirmé certains apports de notre
haute assemblée
l'élargissement de la vaccination
biologiste la prescription des
techniques par des ergothérapeutes la
désignation d'une sage-femme référente
dans le parcours de grossesse ou celle
de référents handicap dans les hôpitaux
nous avons aussi convergé pourrait jeter
le bénévolat individuel dans le contexte
sensible
établissement de santé ou pour autoriser
des professionnels hospitaliers des
établissements de santé privé d'intérêt
collectif espic à maintenir des
dépassements d'honoraires sont menacés
l'accès aux soins
de même sur la gouvernance hospitalière
les députés ont retenu la clarification
opéré par le sénat entre la fonction de
chef de service et de chefs de pôles
ainsi que la meilleure association de la
commission des soins infirmiers à la
conception du projet d'établissement
cependant si nous allons ces
convergences ponctuelles trop de
dispositions formant le coeur de ce
texte nous oppose sans que la navette
est permis à ce stade de faire émerger
des positions de compromis j'ajouterai
madame la ministre que plus qu'à des
désaccords de fond cette à la
publication voici seulement quinze jours
de deux des onze ordonnance promise par
la loi de santé sur les j'ai acheté et
sur l'attractivité des carrières
hospitalières que nous devons les rejets
systématiques et quelque peu contraint
par l'assemblée nationale
des dispositions que nous avions
introduit en première lecture
c'est là une curieuse façon de légiférer
qui fait d'un projet d'ordonnancé encore
en gestation
le censeur politique a priori de nos
amendements sur des dispositions
connexes tels a donc été le sort de nos
articles qui proposait un maillage plus
pertinents et mieux intégrée de l'offre
de soins on donne notamment obligatoire
l'élaboration du projet territorial de
santé afin que la structuration de
l'offre
suivent une trajectoire réellement
ascendante
de la même façon et malgré la revente la
volonté revendiquée par le texte initial
de traduire par voie législative les
recommandations issues des concertations
du secteur de la santé la demande
exprimée par les personnels paramédicaux
d'une participation accrue à la
direction d'établissement et d'une plus
grande représentativité du président la
commission des soins infirmiers que nous
avions satisfaite en première lecture
n'a pas reçu l'accord de l'assemblée
nationale nous avons en revanche été
plus surpris de l'assemblée nationale
par la résurrection de l'article 8 bis
que nous avions probablement supprimer
charge la commission des affaires
sociales du sénat de désigner sur des
critères non défini la sénatrice où le
sénateur qui aura qualité pour siéger au
conseil de surveillance de
l'établissement principal des
établissements publics de santé
ces dispositions ne semble inapplicable
en l'état
mais sur la forme assez discourtoise
nous aurons à coeur de la supprimer
dès que possible enfin madame la
ministre je voudrais rappeler
solennellement devant vous notre
position quant à la lutte contre
l'intérêt médical animés de la même
intention que vous nous avions néanmoins
tenté de vous alerter sur les faux
espoirs que suscite l'idée juridiquement
bancal un contrôle de légalité de la
dépense d'intérêts par le comtat publics
opérés à l'issue de l'engagement de
cette dernière
le circuit de la dépense publique qui
oblige ces ordinateurs à l'égard des
prestataires qu'il sollicite ne permet
pas que le contrôle d'opportunité de la
dépense interviennent au moment de son
paiement
les intérimaires est un signe le plus
souvent et des directeurs d'hôpitaux
contraint des conventions de prestation
parfaitement légale contesterait ce
défaut de paiement devant les tribunaux
administratifs et remporterait leur
contentieux
l'assemblée nationale a considéré que le
recours aux instruments budgétaires
ordinaires de l'hôpital dont on des
ports dont on déplore souvent
l'excellent détail n'était pour
l'occasion pas assez précis pour
détecter en amont un recours abusif à
l'intérim la proposition de notre
commission l'a contredite qui comptait
bien bel et bien faire figurer ses
dépenses individuelles facturés par
intérimaire aux comptes financiers de
l'établissement et permettre ainsi à la
rs d'empêcher des le stade de
l'engagement une dépenses irrégulières
et de neutraliser le risque de
contentieux ultérieure
l'avenir seul dira si nos craintes
étaient justifiées
et si la solution que vous proposez et
opérante permettez moi mes chers
collègues de conclure ce propos par un
sujet qui bien que ne figurant pas
explicitement au sein de la proposition
de loi ne peut être passé sous silence
alors que nous débattons de l'avenir de
l'hôpital public
je veux évoquer les camps nombreuses et
légitimes exprimées en ce moment
al'approche des épreuves de sélection
pour l'entrée en deuxième année les
étudiants en santé de première année qui
achève ses premières étapes de leur
parcours en faisant face pour un nombre
de places identique aux anciens
étudiants de la paces de l'an dernier
admis au redoublement
votre prédécesseur madame le ministre
avait fort bien anticipé ce problème en
promettant lors du vote de la loi santé
qu'une part d'augmentation pour cette
seule année du nombre d'étudiants admis
en deuxième année serait spécifiquement
dédié à la gestion de ces redoublant
afin de ne pas créer des inégalités au
détriment des étudiants primant les
chiffres progressivement arrêtée par les
différentes universités dont la
transparence et malheureusement
dégradées depuis la mise en place du
numerus à perthus confirme que cet
engagement ne sera malheureusement pas
respecté
de très nombreux parlementaires ont
tenté de saisir de cette question par
tous moyens votre collègue frédéric
vidal ministre d'enseignement supérieur
qui n'a pour l'heure fourni à la
représentation nationale que des
réponses évasives peut-être madame la
ministre pourrait vous partagez sur ce
sujet des éléments susceptibles de nous
rassurer
pour l'heure alors que le sénat se
prononce en nouvelle lecture sur ce
texte la commission des affaires
sociales a décidé d'opposer la question
préalable et vous demandera de voter
cette motion
je vous remercie merci madame la
présidente
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à madame laurence cohen
pour le groupe crc e pour 4 minutes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
mes chers collègues le président de la
république a annoncé hier mercredi de
nouvelles mesures pour lutter contre la
pandémie de kovy de 19 et le sénat
débute l'examen en nouvelle lecture de
la proposition de loi visant à améliorer
notre système de santé
or nous savons toutes et tous que notre
système de santé souffre plus que jamais
avec cette pandémie d'un manque de lits
de personnel et de services surchargé
nous savons pertinemment que les
personnels soignants qui sont en
première ligne sont épuisés la tension
est tellement forte que bon nombre de
médecins nous alerte sur le risque de
tri des patients dans les services de
réanimation mais également pour les
déprogrammations d'interventions
chirurgicales entraînant des pertes de
chance
d'ailleurs les nouvelles restrictions
annoncées par le président de la
république sont liées en partie à
l'insuffisance de nos capacités
hospitalières
ce qu'il n'a pas caché notre groupe ne
cesse de dénoncer les politiques menées
depuis plus de 20 ans qui de coupes
budgétaires en coupes budgétaires sont
responsables de l'état de nos hôpitaux
publics et de l'affaiblissement de notre
système de santé
alors cette proposition loi n'est pas à
la hauteur des enjeux
elle est déconnectée de la réalité des
hôpitaux et n'est pas de nature à
redresser la barre pire certaines
mesures vont encore aggraver la
situation
ainsi en renforçant l'autonomie des
hôpitaux et des groupement hospitalier
de territoire cette proposition de loi
amplifie l'affaiblissement du service
public national de santé on le voit déjà
dans les projets en cours pour ne
prendre qu'un exemple la création
programmée à saint-ouen d'un hôpital
cathédrale pour remplacer les hôpitaux
bichat et beaujon va entraîner la
suppression de près de 400 lits et 2200
emplois comment justifier que la
modernisation indispensable de ces
hôpitaux entraînerait une réduction des
capacités d'hospitalisation dans une
zone qui souffre déjà d'un manque de
structures hospitalières
ce que demande la coordination composée
de personnels de syndicalistes d'élus de
patients d'habitantes et d'habitants du
secteur et non seulement de moderniser
bichat et beaujon mais également de
construire un nouvel hôpital
j'étais encore à leurs côtés ce matin
pour faire entendre ses exigences devant
l'hôpital bichat
mais outre ces
on structurelles permettez moi de
m'arrêter sur trois questions traitées
dans cette proposition de loi
premièrement l'élargissement des
missions des psychologues de l'éducation
nationale auquel nous nous opposons
aujourd'hui à l'école il y as pénurie de
médecins et de psychologues scolaires
il faut donc embauché revaloriser leur
profession et non modifié leur mission
deuxièmement concernant la demande
ancienne des orthophonistes visant à
autoriser l'accès direct aux soins
orthophonique afin de mieux orienter un
certain nombre de patients et de
fluidifier leur parcours de soins nous
regrettons les reculs du gouvernement
face à la pression de certaines
coopérations corporation pardon qui a
supprimé l'amendement adopté par le
sénat dans un très large consensus
madame la ministre je vous alerte sur ce
point enfin troisièmement je voudrais
redire ici qu'il ya urgence à intégrer
dans les objectifs du projet social des
hôpitaux la lutte contre les
comportements sexistes racistes et
homophobes
je vous renvoie à madame la ministre mes
chers collègues à une enquête de l'anem
association étudiante de médecine publié
le 18 mars 2021 selon laquelle un tiers
des étudiants et des étudiantes en
médecine ont déjà été victimes de
harcèlement sexuel en stage et selon
laquelle dans neuf cas sur dix le
harceleur est un supérieur beaucoup de
manques des propositions qui conforte
les politiques menées jusqu'à présent
autant de raisons pour nous opposer à
cette proposition de loi en seconde
lecture comme en première lecture je
vous remercie
merci la parole est maintenant madame
élisabeth doineau pour le groupe union
centriste pour six minutes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
comme madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales mes
chers collègues
madame la ministre j'aurais aimé
partager la même satisfaction que vous
tout à l'heure mais lors de la
commission mixte paritaire qui s'est
tenue le 2 mars dernier
je partager mon malaise face à la
proposition de loi de madame la députée
stéphanie rist
évidemment je salue l'intention votre
intention
je salue la mise en place de ce c'est
dur mais avouons le il y a encore des
oubliés du ségur madame la ministre nous
étions en conférence avec un certain
nombre de leurs représentants dans le
département de la mayenne et je peux
vous dire que pour mes collègues il n'y
a pas une semaine où ils ne sont pas
interpellés par ces mêmes oublier pour
dire que ce n'est pas tout à fait normal
que les mêmes professionnels n'est pas
comment eu la même rémunération en tout
cas la même revalorisation de leur
rémunération
j'ai même des siens qui me disent que
cette année ils auront du mal à
remplacer les infirmiers pendant les
vacances
le texte issu de l'assemblée nationale a
cependant suscité beaucoup d'intérêt et
à l'interpellation émanant de toutes les
professions de santé et sa d'âge a
d'ailleurs était déjà évoquée en
première lecture le texte de la
rapporteur a subi à l'assemblée
nationale de nombreuses transformations
ce qui est déjà en soi était une alerte
d'autres sont intervenus au sénat
jusqu'aux dernières heures précédant la
commission mixte paritaire nous
recevions encore les uns et les autres
quantité de demandes et d'interpellation
au sujet de ce texte
je suis donc très ennuyé par cette
proposition de loi dans la rédaction ne
semble pas convenir à de nombreuses
professions
ce qui est particulièrement
problématique avec les membres de mon
groupe nous avions approuvé et salué les
mesures budgétaires du ségur tout en
soulignant qu'il y avait des oubliés
aujourd'hui cette proposition de loi qui
se voulait la traduction de la partie
non budgétaires des conclusions du ségur
je les dis
n'atteint que très partiellement cet
objectif je veux retenir néanmoins de ce
texte les avancées bienvenue relative à
la profession de sage-femme
le chapitre 2 lui majoritairement
consacrée il prévoit notamment la
possibilité pour la patiente de désigner
une sage-femme référente afin de
favoriser la coordination des soins en
lien avec le médecin
il sera aussi désormais possible pour
une sage-femme d'adresser ses patientes
à un médecin spécialiste sans pénaliser
ces dernières en termes de remboursement
par l'assurance maladie des frais de
soins
il s'agit d'une mesure de simplification
de parcours de santé bienvenus c'est
d'ailleurs l'objet de la proposition de
loi
je réitère enfin le point de vigilance
que j'ai pu exposer en première lecture
nous ne pouvons étendre indéfiniment le
champ d'intervention de ces
professionnels sans améliorer leur
statut
un statut qui est hybride actuellement
puisqu'il est médicale devant la loi
mais souvent paramédical pour
l'administration
un chantier devrait se tenir afin de
mieux faire cadrer leur statut avec
leurs compétences déjà quatre journées
de mobilisation sont retenus depuis le
début de l'année les 26 janvier 10 et 24
février
et dernièrement le 8 mars les sages
femmes sont à bout l'heure est aux
mesures concrètes
elle demande notamment l'augmentation
des effectifs la reconnaissance de leur
statut de profession médicale à
l'hôpital
un alignement des salaires sur les
autres professionnels de santé ainsi que
l'ouverture de négociations
conventionnelles dans le cadre du
rapport des mille jours
je souhaite que la mission de l'igas qui
devrait remettre ses conclusions d'ici
l'été permettra d'aboutir à une
traduction à la hauteur des enjeux
lors du prochain plfss je ne m'étendrai
pas davantage sur le fond du texte je
vous redis mon malaise et ma perplexité
après tout les auditions et le travail
mené sur ce texte
je regrette que le sénat et l'assemblée
nationale n'ait pu s'entendre
de nombreux points de divergence nous
c'est pas aussi je ne vois pas ce qui
peut nous réunir au delà de quelques
articles consensuel améliorée par le
sénat je partage l'analyse de notre
rapporteur alain milon
je le cite sur le coeur des dispositions
l'assemblée nationale a rétabli pour
l'essentiel son texte de première
lecture notamment en matière de
gouvernance hospitalière alors que le
sénat avait adopté des propositions
constructives sur des points concrets de
cette évolution
dans ces conditions pour suivre le débat
n'aurait pas tellement de sens et
risqueraient en définitive de créer de
faux espoirs auprès des professionnels
de santé
aussi les sénateurs du groupe union
centriste en prenant acte et voteront
favorablement la motion tendant à
opposer la question préalable
je voudrais dire combien mes collègues
du groupe union centriste sont très
attentifs à ce que vous puissiez
améliorer l'ensemble des professionnels
concernés par le ségur notamment sur les
efforts budgétaires
nous avons aujourd'hui la possibilité de
connaître les conclusions de monsieur
laforcade qui a été missionné sur cette
question nous aimerions en connaître les
résultats
pour ce qui est des mesures mon
budgétaire on sent qu'il y a des
frustrés on a encore aujourd'hui des
mails et des appels qui nous parviennent
pour cette raison le groupe union
centriste ne peut cautionner finalement
cette proposition de loi
parce que ça voudrait dire que
finalement on accepte qu'il y ait des
oubliés et des frustrés du ségur
merci madame jouanno la parole est
maintenant pour six minutes à monsieur
bernard jomier pour le groupe socialiste
ces coupes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
mes chers collègues nous nous retrouvons
donc à nouveau pour étudier ce texte
dans un contexte marqué par la crise que
nous connaissons il y a un an les
françaises et les français applaudissent
et spontanément le personnel soignant
après une année très difficile
un dévouement sans précédent des
professions soignante le décès de
beaucoup d'entre eux tous avaient
imaginé une prise de conscience
collective et un appui ferme et unanime
des pouvoirs publics
ils auront entendu hier soir le chef de
l'état leur demander de nouveaux efforts
et pour répondre à leurs demandes
le gouvernement propose un texte
largement insuffisant d'ailleurs marqué
en cours d'examen par des rétro pédalage
et des ajouts de dernière minute
un texte qui ne répond qu'à une vraiment
infime part des besoins et n'y répondent
pas toujours bien cette proposition de
loi apparaît ainsi plus que jamais en
décalage avec les besoins matériels et
humains dans notre système de soins
besoin et c'est la raison pour laquelle
l'écrasante majorité des syndicats des
associations de professionnels s'est
positionné contre son adoption
vous avez fait le choix de légiférer
dans une certaine forme de précipitation
et malgré d'importantes contributions du
sénat l'assemblée nationale
in fine est rétabli son texte pour
l'essentiel cette ppl avait pour
ambition de réaffirmer le rôle des
services et du chef de service dans la
gouvernance de l'hôpital
nous pensons en effet il constitue une
unité pertinente dans la prise de
décisions d'organisation et de mise en
oeuvre de l'offre de soins et que les
réformes successives de l'hôpital où ils
les ont trop éloignés des instances
décisionnelles
mais au fond à l'arrivée ce texte ne
procède ni un réel changement de cap ni
à une nouvelle répartition des
compétences entre les pôles d'activité
les services
qu'attendent les personnels hospitaliers
la gouvernance de l'hôpital avec cette
loi ne répondra toujours pas à la
reconnaissance du rôle des soignants pas
plus qu'elle ne tire vraiment les leçons
de la crise et par exemple vous n'avez
pas tiré les enseignements de cette
période du printemps dernier où
l'hôpital
malgré la surcharge extrême fonctionner
mieux car l'administration était au
service des soignants et non en
complications et en limitation
permanente de leurs actions confiance et
simplification dites vous quand le 17
mars dernier à l'issue du conseil des
ministres le président de la république
signe deux ordonnances déclinant la loi
du 24 juillet 2019 relative à
l'organisation et à la transformation du
système de santé une de ces ordonnance
est relative au groupement hospitalier
de territoire et à la médicalisation des
décisions à l'hôpital et la seconde vise
à favoriser l'attractivité des carrières
médicales hospitalières
or déjà sur la forme vous ne respectez
pas le principe de l' ordonnance en
juillet 2019
quand le parlement vous donner sa
confiance pour légiférer de la sorte
afin de se donner le temps d'un travail
rigoureux associant l'ensemble des
représentants des professions concernées
et bien au fond à l'arrivée comment
pouvez vous estimer que les
concertations ont été menées dans de
bonnes conditions alors qu'il en résulte
un rejet massif des organisations
syndicales et que un collectif
regroupant largement les médecins
dénoncent dans un communiqué récent des
ordonnances je cite écrite à marche
forcée ces derniers mois aboutissant
lors du conseil supérieur des personnels
médicaux pour la première un vote
unanimement défavorable de l'ensemble
des représentants des praticiens et pour
le second texte un vote majoritairement
défavorable de cette représentation
voilà comment les premiers concernés
jugent cette loi et sur le fond ces deux
ordonnances reprennent les thématiques
de la ppl que nous votons actuellement
alors quelle crédibilité accorder ou pas
le mans pour le traiter ainsi et c'est
en notre note entre autres par dont vous
vous en souvenez pour cette raison qu'en
première lecture le groupe socialistes
écologistes et républicains avaient
proposé une motion de renvoi en
commission les leçons de la pandémie ne
sont toujours pas tiré c'est pas
surprenant mais en vérité soignants
comme parlementaire nous attendons une
loi santé à la hauteur de l'engagement
de nos professionnels de santé à la
hauteur des transformations nécessaires
du système de soins nous en sommes
tellement loin que poursuivre ce débat
n'est pas utile c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous voterons la motion tendant
à opposer la question préalable sur
merci merci chers collègues la parole et
maintenat madame colette mélot pour le
groupe des indépendants pour 4 minutes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
chers collègues la proposition de loi
que nous examinons à présent en nouvelle
lecture présente un ensemble de mesures
non budgétaires issus des conclusions du
ségur de la santé je regrette comme
beaucoup d'entre nous l'échec de la
commission mixte paritaire le 2 mars
dernier et la suppression par
l'assemblée nationale de la plupart des
mesures adopté au sénat
les désaccords portent essentiellement
sur trois points les protocoles de
coopération et de la création d'une
profession médicale intermédiaires les
moyens de lutter contre les dérives de
l'intérim médicale et la gouvernance
hospitalière
l'amendement porté par alain marc visant
à étendre le dispositif d'exercice en
pratique avancée aux infirmiers
anesthésistes a été supprimée en
nouvelle lecture à l'assemblée nationale
la disposition proposée par franck mais
non ville visant à renforcer le rôle des
élus au sein du conseil de surveillance
des établissements de santé a également
été supprimée à l'assemblée nationale
d'autres mesures importantes ont connu
un sort similaire
je pense notamment à l'autorisation de
primes aux prescriptions et à la
délivrance du traitement de prévention
du vih par les médecins de ville et les
pharmaciens que le gouvernement a jugé
prématuré lorsqu'il est question de la
santé de nos concitoyens je pense qu'il
n'est jamais trop tôt pour agir
la navette parlementaire a néanmoins
contribué à enrichir le texte la
possibilité de désigner une sage-femme
référente a été conservé ainsi que
l'extension de l'acte de vaccination aux
pharmacies aux pharmaciens et aux
biologistes les orthophonistes et les
masseurs kinésithérapeutes les
ergothérapeutes je crois aussi auront
bientôt la possibilité d'adapter des
prescriptions mais d'idées médicale ces
mesures concrètes contribueront à
faciliter le parcours de soin des
patients
je partage la réflexion de notre
rapporteur alain milon sur l'article 1er
instituant une nouvelle profession
médicale l'exercice en pratique avancée
répondent précisément l'objectif
d'ajouter un maillon supplémentaire dans
l'offre de soins sans pour autant la
rendre plus
plex est donc moins accessible en
revanche je suis favorable à certaines
avancées plus volontaire de l'assemblée
nationale en matière d'accès à la santé
le renouvellement des axes des arrêts de
travail de plus de 15 jours par
l'ensemble des sages-femmes la
prescription de traitement des ist aux
partenaires ainsi que leur eau leur
autorisation à orienter leurs patientes
vers la médecine spécialisée
d'autre part la création de la
plateforme numérique d'accès au droit
pour les personnes en situation de
handicap est une disposition importante
porté par cette proposition de loi
mon collègue daniel chassaing de
proposer en séance d'étendre le bénéfice
de cette plateforme aux personnes âgées
dépendantes
l'examen du projet de loi grand âge sera
l'occasion de réexaminer cette
proposition le texte présenté propose
des avancées intéressantes mais
conformément aux usages de notre groupe
nous avons choisi de ne pas voter la
motion déposée par la commission nous
souhaitons poursuivre les discussions et
l'examen des amendements que nous avons
déposés je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant madame raymonde poncet monge
pour le groupe écologiste pour 4 minutes
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
madame la présidente de la commission
lors de la première lecture nous avions
pointé la déception et les inquiétudes
de la majorité des acteurs de santé
quant à cette proposition de loi le
texte marqué une véritable incapacité à
se saisir des enseignements de la crise
sanitaire pointé lors du ségur de la
santé tout comme pour le versant
financier où malgré un début de
rattrapage du décrochage des
rémunérations le gouvernement n'en
poursuit pas moins aujourd'hui les
projets de fermetures de lits ce versant
dit non financiers du ségur témoigne
d'un rendez-vous en grande partie manqué
aujourd'hui et ce n'est pas un poisson
d'avril
l'hôpital militaire des jeunes est de
lyon ferme
aujourd'hui ces urgences alors que son
service de médecine sous employés
pouvaient accueillir les patients qu'aux
vide ne nécessitant pas ou plus de
réanimation à deux pas de l'hôpital
public edouard herriot
aujourd'hui saturé la caf continue comme
les acteurs de santé
nous avons apporté notre contribution
pour que cette crise ouvre sur une
rénovation profonde de notre système de
santé au sénat le travail parlementaire
avait perdu permis de supprimer les
articles
unanimement contesté lors des auditions
et pour le groupe écologiste de salué
quelques avancées
je pense bien sûr à la possibilité pour
la femme enceinte de désigner une
sage-femme référente et également au
sénat à l'accès direct aux soins
d'orthophonie défendu largement sur nos
bancs la majorité des articles les plus
contestés ont été rétablies par
l'assemblée nationale notamment celui
sont la compétence de recrutement donné
à l'établissement support du j'ai acheté
pour le compte des établissements partie
ce rétablissement valide l'analyse et
les craintes des acteurs locaux de santé
d'une intégration principalement au
service d'une logique d'économie et non
malheureusement pour construire une
offre hospitalière efficiente mayans
l'ensemble du territoire
le bilan quant à la réforme de la
gouvernance hospitalière
je reste bien pauvre ainsi l'assemblée
nationale valide la suppression de la
concertation interne préalable à la
nomination du chef de service demander
effectivement par la majorité
sénatoriale mais n'a pas l'audace
d'expérimenter l'élection de ce même
chef de service par ses pairs l'article
qui renforce la lutte contre le recours
abusif à l'intérim
objectif qui fait l'unanimité ne
s'attaquent nullement à ses causes la
pénurie dans certaines spécialités
médicales aggravée par le décrochage des
rémunération des praticiens hospitaliers
qui voient certains préféré l'exercice
en clinique privée explique le recours
aux dépassements d'honoraires jusqu'au
mode le plus dégradé l'intérim et ses
abus ce n'est pas d'injonctions
paradoxales fait taux directeur entre
continuité du service refuse refus du
chantage ou fermeture des services qui
peut constituer la seule réponse pour ne
pas dire une défausse du gouvernement
enfin le comble a été atteint quand
l'accès direct ou soit en orthophonie
qui avait le soutien des deux
commissions social de la robe de la
rapporteur de l'assemblée lors de la
queue de la commission et de la majorité
du sénat a non seulement été supprimée
par un amendement de dernière minute du
gouvernement mais a fait l'objet d'une
régression inédite de l'autonomie de la
profession quant au diagnostic
orthophonique et à l'élaboration du
traitement une telle impéritie at-elle
passage aux forces nous conduit à
condamner la méthode en plus du fonds et
à ne plus voir nous aussi l'intérêt de
poursuivre l'examen de ce texte
le groupe écologiste solidarité
territoire veux te ra en conséquence la
question préalable
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant madame nicole duranton pour
le beau-père des pays pour quatre
minutes
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre madame la présidente de la
commission
chers collègues les plus grands artistes
sont ceux qui possède le don de
simplification à l' usage des autres
écrivez claude lelouch c'est vrai aussi
des décisions en matière de politique
publique la confiance mutuelle des
acteurs de la santé est le préalable
nécessaire à toute simplification la
simplification
elle est devenue un enjeu majeur pour
permettre à chaque soignant d'effectuer
sa mission au mieux et à chaque patient
d'être soignés et rembourser
efficacement pendant cette crise
sanitaire cette simplification a trouvé
sa nécessité absolue d'une part pour
désengorger les urgences
d'autre part pour permettre la
continuité des soins habituels
à ce titre l'élargissement de la
télémédecine rembourser pour tous quel
que soit le département du médecin a
permis d'assurer l'accès aux soins
notamment dans les zones sous dotées
comme mon département de l'eure j'ai
d'ailleurs écrit il ya quelques jours à
monsieur le ministre de la santé pour
lui demander la pérennisation de cette
simplification au delà de la crise
sanitaire
la ppl dont nous débattons aujourd'hui
constitue la traduction législative des
mesures issues les conclusions du ségur
de la santé pour la partie non
budgétaires le texte a été enrichi lors
de sa première lecture au sénat
et je souhaite souligner le travail du
rapporteur mon collègue alain mignon et
de la commission des affaires sociales
certaines de ces mesures ont été
conservés par l'assemblée nationale
je pense à l'ouverture du droit de
vaccination aux pharmaciens et
biologistes ou aux dépassements
d'honoraires des professionnels libéraux
en sp2 articles provenant d'un
amendement porté par le groupe air des
pays ont également été adoptées
conformément par les deux chambres et
nous nous en félicitons
l'article 7 bis b visant à assurer
l'interopérabilité du système
d'information au sein des groupements
haut
pitallier territoriaux l'article 14 bis
à permettant la mise en place d'un
référent handicap au sein de chaque
établissement de santé
l'assemblée a rétabli les suppression du
sénat cela concerne notamment des
dispositions que notre groupe soutenait
lors de la première lecture tels que le
rapport sur la création d'une profession
intermédiaire la lutte contre les
dérives de l'intérêt médical ou encore
le projet managériale
face à ces modifications notion pendant
a reposé la question préalable a été
déposé or il serait regrettable
d'arrêter ici les échanges et de nier
que ce texte porte des mesures
essentielles demandé par les soignants
depuis des années et d'autres méritant
sans doute encore un travail
d'amélioration mais qui ne justifie pas
un tel rejet en bloc les demandes des
professionnels de santé ont été entendus
avec notamment 754 millions d'euros
supplémentaires engagés pour les
urgences pour la période 2010 9 2022
le rapport clarisse et le ségur de la
santé ont permis de préciser ses
demandes
cette ppl représente ainsi plusieurs
avancées concrètes
l'élargissement des protocoles locaux de
coopération l'évolution du rôle des
sages femmes en leur permettant
notamment de prescrire des arrêts
maladie et de les prolonger
l'élargissement du droit de prescription
pour elle et les masseurs
kinésithérapeutes la réinstallation de
la fonction de chef de service
la lutte contre les dérives de l'intérêt
médical ou encore la prise en compte des
étudiants en santé dans l'élaboration du
projet social pour défendre toutes ces
avancées et parce que nous croyons
profondément en la valeur des débats
dans cet hémicycle
le groupe air des pays est favorable à
ce texte mais votera contre la motion de
questions préalables je vous remercie
merci jacques lahaye la parole est
maintenant vadam maryse carrère pour
l'europe rds pour 4 minutes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le président la commission
mes chers collègues nous voilà une fois
encore réuni afin d'examiner la
proposition de loi visant à améliorer le
système de santé par la confiance et la
simplification
suite à l'échec de la réunion de la
commission mixte paritaire du 2 mars
l'assemblée nationale a essentiellement
rétabli son texte et la compléter
concernant le statut des sages-femmes
l'assemblée nationale a décidé de
quelque peu dérogé au respect du
parcours de soins centrés sur le mid
east médecin traitant qui devait pour
nous demeurer le principe
à propos de la gouvernance des
établissements publics de santé
le sénat avait exclu la présence
d'étudiants en scène de leur directoire
cette possibilité a été rétablie par
l'assemblée et nous nous en réjouissons
cela permettra de faire connaître la
vision et les attentes des jeunes
c'est un signal positif que nous leur
adressons sur la lutte contre les
dérives de l'intérim l'assemblée a
rétabli le dispositif permettant aux
directeurs généraux des ars de déférer
devant le tribunal administratif les
contrats irrégulier il donne également
des pouvoirs au comptable public
quand certains considèrent que cela peut
mettre les directeurs d'établissements
en difficulté nous pensons au contraire
que cela leur enlève une responsabilité
et les protège un bilan d'étape sera
nécessaire sur ce point qu'il faudra
évaluer avec prudence et pragmatisme a
également été rétablie l'intégration
d'un projet managériale au projet au
projet d'établissement des
établissements publics de santé dont
nous sommes convaincus de l'utilité
on ne saurait réduire la maîtrise des
techniques managériale à des enjeux de
rentabilité bien au contraire elles
permettent d'améliorer le fonctionnement
des équipes et des services je salue le
maintient par l'assemblée de plusieurs
de nos propositions
je pense à l'extension des compétences
des professions paramédicales
l'idée était d'étendre le champ de leurs
prérogatives
ainsi des ergothérapeutes les
orthophonistes les masseurs
kinésithérapeutes ont vu leur droit de
prescription est tendue je pense
également à la possibilité donnée aux
pharmacies à usage intérieur et aux
laboratoires d'analysés de biologie
médicale d'effectuer certains actes de
vaccination proposition que le groupe
rdse
avait introduite nous déplorons
néanmoins de la suppression de certains
rapports du sénat comme le déploiement
de l'exercice en pratique avancée